SUB COMMITTEE THREE TODAY. HAS A
WE HAVE FOR THE PAST A COUPLE
YEARS WERE HAVING AN IN PERSON
HEARING IN THE STATE CAPITAL
TODAY WERE IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA WILL BE APPEARING
REMOTELY HUSING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY AND THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON MAY DO SO WHEN
WE OPEN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THE HEARING. AFTER
THOSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM OF
SPOKEN WE WILL ALLOW PHONE
TESTIMONY THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ALSO ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER TO
CALL IN. TOLL FREE IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN THAT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE. IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE NINE.
AGAIN THAT'S. NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE NINE. AND
A FRIENDLY STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. ALL COMMENTERS WILL
HAVE UP TO ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK.
WE WILL BE TAKING ANY VOTES
TODAY AND ALL ITEMS REGARDING
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE- IF YOU'RE EXPECTING TO
HEAR- ABOUT THOSE TODAY. I'M SAD
TO TELL YOU THEY'VE BEEN MOVED
TO MARCH SECOND SO THE-
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
ISSUES MOVED TO MARCH SECOND.
WE'LL START WITH OUR FIVE
DISCUSSION ITEMS AND FIRST WILL
LEAD TO ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
GIVE THEIR TESTIMONY AND THEN
OPEN IT UP TO QUESTIONS FROM
OUR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AFTER
THE FIVE DISCUSSION ITEMS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY ASK
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ABOUT THE
NON DISCUSSION ITEMS AND WILL
END. WITH OUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE'RE NOT READY TO TAKE ROLE YET
BUT WE CAN BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. WITH OUR FIRST
ISSUE TO BE HEARD FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. WE'RE
GOING TO BE HEARING ABOUT OTHER
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PACKAGE THAT
TO HOW WE'RE GONNA SPEND THAT
MONEY THAT WE PASSED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. THAT'S A THREE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS SO. A
LOT OF- RESOURCES BEING
ALLOCATED TO THOSE ITEMS AND-
I'M SORT OF VAMPING HERE WAITING
FOR SOMEBODY TO APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN- TO HAVE THE- LA- READY
TO SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE. ARRIGO.
YOUR MUTED. OR MAYBE THREE RIGHT
TRY AGAIN. SORRY CAN YOU DON'T
KNOW YEAH IT WAS ALL ME. ALL I
HAVE. CRISTINA LEGISLATIVE IN
ARE THANK SO MUCH FOR HAVING
TODAY- I DID YOUR ATTENTION LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDED
THREE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
AND PRIVATE RESILIENCE PACKAGE
THAT WAS ONE OF. IF I'M NOT
HAPPY THAT WOULD HAVE LAST YEAR
. WOULD IF YOU ARE QUITE ON. GET
UP FOR SECOND WHILE WE JUST
VOLUME LIKE WE DID LAST WEEK.
YOUR OUR VOLUME GUINEA PIG AGAIN. DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT YOU DID
LAST WEEK I'LL TRY AGAIN I THINK
I CAN SPEAK MORE LOUDLY ABOUT
TOTAL. YOUR PERFECT AT THE WITH
THE VOLUME ON OUR SIDE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WOULD YOU MIND BEGIN
YEAH. SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME TODAY MY NAME IS KHAN
CRISTINA THE LATEST LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- ON. WEDNESDAY
CHAIR MENTIONED LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THREE POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN A CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE AND I DID A
GREAT SPENDING IN A VARIETY OF
AREAS RELATED TO CLIMATE
RESILIENCE I KNOW IT'S PART IN
SEVERAL MAJOR ENVIRONMENTAL
PACKAGES THAT WERE PASSED LAST
YEAR. AND IT PROVIDED OVER AND
OVER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD AND WE
DID HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS WE
WANTED TO PROVIDE I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION MAY HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AND I UPDATE ON WHERE
THEY ARE ON THAT PACKAGE. BUT
WHAT WE WANTED TO POINT OUT IS
THAT IN IN A NUMBER OF CASES.
PENDING WITH SCHEDULED OUT
ALREADY FOR THIS YEAR- BUT THERE
WAS THERE A COUPLE NOTABLE
EXCEPTIONS SO- BUT THERE IS
QUITE A BIT OF MONEY PROVIDED
FOR NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS. AND
EXTREME HEAT- BUT THOSE WERE
PROVIDED INSTEAD OF SITES SO
THAT THEIR THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
I. ABOUT HOW THOSE BANDS WERE TO
BE SPENT THOSE BY WERE TO BECOME
IN THIS THIS YEAR. TWENTY
TWENTY. I'M UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION IN. TO FORWARD
WITH A PROPOSAL WITH THE MORE.
HOW WOULD THOSE- THAT THAT MAY
HAVE IN THIS. BUT WE HAVEN'T
THAT YOU. I'M WE- THINK THAT
WOULD BE. HOLD AS PART OF. THIS
HEARING IS FOR THE- AFFECTING
ABOUT THE FUN. THINKING ABOUT
WHY- WHAT IT WOULD LIKE TO DO
WITH THE FRIENDS- AND ALSO I AM
. HOPEFUL ENCOURAGE BETTER.
MINUTES PROVIDE SOME. ON MY
THEIR PLAN IS WHEN THEY MAKE
COME FOR WITH MORE DETAIL. SPACE
SORT OF SKETCH AN PROPOSAL. TO
HOW THEY'RE GONNA SEND THOSE
FUNDS. I'M BECAUSE WHEN IT CAN
BE VERY CHALLENGING I JUST. IS
ALL YOU KNOW I'M IT. IS RECEIVE
A LOT OF. IN WHEN A VERY. TIME
FRAME AND THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
TIME TO REALLY CONSIDER THE
MERITS. I'M AND THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF MONEY AND-
IT'S HARD TO PACKAGE THE WHOLE
AS WELL AS FOR THIS TO SPECIFIC.
AREAS AND SO I'M REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
MAKE SURE IT'S COMFORTABLE WITH
WHATEVER PLAN ADMINISTRATION
COMES FORWARD WITH HOPEFULLY
HAVE AS MUCH TIME AS POSSIBLE TO
CONSIDER IT- AND REALLY START
THINKING ABOUT THOSE THINGS
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT
TO PROVIDE. SPECIFIC GUIDANCE
FOR EXAMPLE AS PART OF TRAILER
BILL OR BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE
SPENT REALLY IN A WAY THAT
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. AND SO THAT'S OUR
MAIN COMMENTS ON THAT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS. EITHER NOW OR
AFTER THAT AND I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION MAY ALSO BE
AVAILABLE. I'M TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF AN UPDATE ON WHERE
THEY ARE AND THAT'S FINE AND- I
THINK THIS. THERE'S TO BE. AS
WELL AS LARGER PACK. GREAT THANK
YOU- I WOULD. QUESTION EFFORTS
ARE. TILL AFTER. ALL OF THE-
YOU. CAN MANAGEMENT STEP WE- THE
THAT THE RESOURCES AGENCY.
EVERYONE THIS IS A HANSEN THAT
SECRETARY CLIMATE THE NATURAL
THE CAN YOU HEAR ME. RIGHT OKAY
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE-
I TO WALK THROUGH PRO TO THE
STATUS AGREE TO AN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. AND AS YOU ALL KNOW BEEN
WORKING WITH PARTNERS ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION GEN. AT TO
DEVELOP THREE PLANS THAT ARE
VERY CRITICAL TO DELIVERING ON
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND
BIODIVERSITY GOALS. THE FIRST IS
OUR NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY THIS WAS
CALLED OR AND THE GOVERNOR'S
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS EXECUTIVE
ORDER IT'S REALLY INTENDED TO
SET OUT A VISION FOR GUIDING AND
ACCELERATING LAND MANAGEMENT
THAT DELIVERS ON CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS. BOTH CARBON
NEUTRALITY AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE. SECOND STRATEGY THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON IT IS OUR
THIRTY BY THIRTY PATHWAY
STRATEGY. WHICH WAS ALSO CALLED
FOR IN THE GOVERNOR'S NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS EXECUTIVE ORDER.
AND IT'S INTENDED TO OUTLINE OUR
APPROACH TO ACHIEVING THE GOAL
OF CONSERVING 30% OF OUR LANDS
AND COASTAL WATERS BY TWENTY
THIRTY. AND THE FINAL PLAN UNDER
WAY IS OUR EXTREME HEAT ACTION
PLAN. WHICH WAS DEVELOPED AS A
RESULT OF OUR WORK TO UPDATE THE
STATE'S ADAPTATION STRATEGY AND
REALIZING WE REALLY NEEDED
STRATEGIC AND COMPREHENSIVE SET.
OF STATE ACTIONS TO ADAPT TO AND
BUILD RESILIENCE TO EXTREME
HEAT- HELLO ALL OF THESE
STRATEGIES WERE DEVELOPED
THROUGH EXTENSIVE PUBLIC INPUT
OVER THE COURSE OF LAST YEAR- WE
HELD REGIONAL WORKSHOP WE HAD
NUMEROUS COMPLICATIONS WITH
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES. AND WE HELD AN EXTREME
HEAT WORKSHOP SERIES. FEEDBACK
THAT WE RECEIVED THROUGH ALL OF
THIS ENGAGEMENT. HAS DEEPLY
INFLUENCED BOTH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE DRAFT THAT HAVE ALL BEEN
RELEASED- WE'VE ALSO TAKEN A
REAL YOU ARE HELPFUL APPROACH TO
ENSURING THAT THE FEEDBACK THAT
WE RECEIVED ON THE DRAFT PLANS.
OR FINAL STRATEGIES AS WELL AS
OUR APPROACH TO DEVELOPING
PROPOSALS FOR THE FUTURE OF THE
SOLUTION SET ASIDE AND THE
EXTREME HEAT SET ASIDE WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
BUILDING OUT THOSE FINAL
STRATEGIES AND TO USING THAT
PUBLIC INPUT THAT WE RECEIVE TO
INFORM OUR APPROACH. FOR BCPS
AND- IN THE SPRING SO I'LL STOP
THERE AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING ME. THANK YOU. THANK
GOD- NEXT UP WE HAVE- DOCTOR
GOAL FROM THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL. THE MORNING CARE
BLOEMEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THE
RESOURCES IN THE CURRENT BUDGET
WILL ENABLE THE OCEAN TEXTING
COUNCIL TO PURSUE A NUMBER OF
CRITICAL AREAS RELATED TO
BUILDING CALIFORNIA'S- CULTURE
RESILIENCE ALL OF THESE EFFORTS
ARE CONSISTENT WITH OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN TO PROTECT ON
CALIFORNIA'S COAST AND OCEAN. ON
THE SCIENCE SIDE. WE WILL UPDATE
THE TECH GUIDANCE FOR SEA LEVEL
RISE FOR THE STATE USING THE
LATEST SCIENCE. WELL THE
NATIONAL ASSESSMENT FOR SEA
LEVEL RISE COMES OUT NEXT WEEK
ON FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH AND
THAT'LL BE A VERY CRITICAL PART.
OF ON DEVELOPING THAT GUIDANCE.
ALSO WILL BUILD ON EXISTING
EFFORTS TO COMPLETE A HABITAT
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT FOR
WETLANDS BEACHES AND ROCKY
INTERTIDAL HABITAT. ACTION PLANS
WILL BE DEVELOPED FOR ALL THREE
OF THESE KINDS OF HABITATS
MOVING FORWARD. ON THE
RESTORATION SIDE WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
RESTORATION OF CRITICAL YOUNG
GRASS HABITAT- ALONG- THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. ALONG OUR SHORES AND
ON THE PLANNING SIDE WILL
PROVIDE FUNDING ASSISTANCE
THROUGH YOUR B. C. D. C. A. R.
THEIR BAD DOCTOR EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE COASTAL
RESILIENCE PLAN FOR STARTERS.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STATE PARKS AND SUPPORT THEM. ON
THEIR PART SPECIFIC C. LEVEL
RISE ADAPTATION PLANNING EFFORTS
. AND FINALLY WILL PROVIDE
TECHNICAL CONSULTATION- TO THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY'S EFFORTS TO
FUND PROJECTS TO USE NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS THE BILL CALLED
THE RESILIENCE. ON ON OUR
CALIFORNIA'S COAST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT AS THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY. GOOD MORNING A CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES I CAN GOOD
MORNING RIGHT. HI THIS IS AMY
HOW TALL I AM- THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY AND THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY IS- PROPOSING TO USE
THAT THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE
THAT'S IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
THROUGH OUR EXISTING CLIMATE
READY PROGRAM. TO FIND PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF A BROAD
SUITE OF THE COASTAL RESILIENCE
PROJECTS- WE'RE NOT INTENDING TO
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM THE WE ARE
UPDATING OUR STRATEGIC PLAN THIS
CALENDAR YEAR TO AID OUR STAFF
AND BOARD IN PRIORITIZING
PROJECTS. WE WILL ALSO RELY
HEAVILY ON THE RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE THIRTY BY THIRTY PATHWAY
STRATEGY AND THE NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS CLIMATE SMART
STRATEGY SAID THOSE- REPORTS AND
ALL OF THE PUBLIC INPUT THAT
WENT INTO THOSE REPORTS- WILL
HEAVILY INFLUENCE OF THE-
SPENDING OF OUR COASTAL
RESILIENCE BY- THE COASTAL
CONSERVE. FUNDING WILL FOCUS ON
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY HE'S THAT
HAVE LIMITED OUR CAPACITY TO
PLAN AND IMPLEMENT CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PROJECTS SO
UNDERSERVED. COMMUNITIES ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT LACK- THE
RESOURCES TO UNDERTAKE THIS WORK
. WILL ALSO FOCUS ON NATURE
BASED COASTAL RESILIENCE
PROJECTS SUCH AS PROJECTS THAT
EMPLOY BEACHES DUNES WETLANDS
AND LIVING SHORELINES. I WOULD
NOTE THE GAPS IN THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO ADAPT TO SEA LEVEL
RISE WILL REMAIN EVEN AND WITH
THIS SIGNIFICANT COASTAL
RESILIENCE FUNDING- PARTICULARLY
FOR LOW LYING RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SO I THINK THAT SOMETHING. UP
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE
TO THINK ABOUT. AN OF THE NEEDS
ARE HUGE THE THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION AND IS- AN
EXTREMELY SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
LEVEL FOR THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY- IT IS YOU KNOW ON
PAR WITH SOME OF THE PAST- BOND
FUNDING BUT THIS IS ALL AND- YOU
KNOW ONE YEAR COMING TO US- BUT
THE NEEDS ARE- VERY SIGNIFICANT
WE'RE WORKING ON MAJOR NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. THAT
COULD EASILY USE YOU KNOW CAN
TELL HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON THEIR OWN AND WE WANT
TO REACH AN BUILD A NEW
COMMUNITIES TO UNDERTAKE
PROJECTS- AND TO BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL BE MOST
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THAT LACK THE RESOURCES- TO
UNDERTAKE THE WORK THEMSELVES-
SET THAN. YOU VERY. THANK YOU
DOES- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
. COMMENTS TO ADD. AT THIS IS
CHRIS ARCHER TO WHAT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I DON'T HAVE ANY
FORMAL PRESENTATION OR COMMENTS
BUT- I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU FOR A WHILE WE TAKE
QUESTIONS ON- THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM THIS IS A BIG ONE- AND- ALL
BEGIN BY. ASKING THE- NATURE.
NATURE BASED SET ASIDES FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS- CAN YOU TELL US. HOW
MUCH OF THAT IS INTENDED TO BE
USED FOR CONSERVATION AND- AND-
HOW MUCH FOR OUT REACH HOW MUCH
FOR RESTORATION TO HAVE A-
DIDN'T DO ANY OF YOU HAVE A
BREAK JOHN HOW. THAT'S INTENDED
TO BE UTILIZED. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION AGAIN THE MONEY
HANSEN FROM THE RESOURCES AGENCY
OUT WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING OUT OUR PROPOSALS FOR
THE NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS THAT
ASIDE WE DON'T HAVE A BREAKDOWN
FOR YOU BUT I WILL SAY THAT ALL
THREE OF THOSE GOALS ARE AT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS CRITICAL FOR
ACHIEVING THE GOALS OF BOTH
THIRTY BY THIRTY AND THAT KIND
OF HEARTLAND MANAGEMENT SO YOU
WILL SEE CONSERVATION
RESTORATION AND OUTREACH. IN THE
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD IN THE
SPRING. SO A LOT OF THIS IS IN
FURTHERANCE OF THE F. THIRTY.
I'M SORRY OF THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY CONSERVATION GOAL. WHICH
I THINK IS VERY LAUDABLE AND I
SUPPORTED BUT- HAS THE STATE
DEVELOPED A VISION FOR ACHIEVING
THAT. AND IF SO. LET US KNOW
WHAT IT IS. WELL PERHAPS ALL
TAKE A FIRST CRACK AND THEN
HANDED OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE MARK
IN CASE YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU'D
LIKE TO HAPPEN BECAUSE I KNOW
HE'S BEEN WORKING. CLOSELY ON
THIS BUT I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW
THE VISION FOR A THIRTY BY
THIRTY. IS TO AT. ED SHEERAN
DURING CONSERVATION MEASURES%
THAT DELIVER ON OUR GOALS OF
PROTECTING BIODIVERSITY
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
INCREASING ACCESS TO NATURE THAT
IS OUR VISION FOR THIRTY BY
THIRTY THAT THAT THOSE ARE THE
GOALS- AS WHICH IUNDERSTAND- OF
THE I THINK THE QUESTION IS. HOW
DO WE ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS HOW TO
USE THE RESOURCES- THAT WE'RE
ALLOCATING AT THIS TIME. OF TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS SO- I ASSUME
SOME OF THAT WILL. BE CONTAINED
IN THE BCP THAT'LL BE. COMING AT
US AT AT SOME POINT CAN YOU GIVE
SOME SPECIFICITY AS TO WHEN WE
MAY RECEIVE THAT BCP. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THE B. C. B. WILL BE
COMING THROUGH THE SPRING
PROCESS I CAN ALSO TELL YOU THAT
WE ARE FOCUSED ON ENSURING THERE
IS FUNDING FOR- ACQUISITION AND
EASEMENTS THAT WILL SUPPORT OUR
THIRTY BY THIRTY GOAL. YEAH I
JUST WANNA JUMP AND- OR BRIEF
MOMENT I'M SURE BUT ON. IT IT'S
A CITY IT'S A SYSTEM APPROACH
BASED ON THE PATHWAYS DOCUMENT
AND THE PATHWAYS DOCUMENT ON. I
CAME OUT IN DRAFT FORM AND- YOU
KNOW VERY VERY PUBLIC FIFTEEN
PLUS PUBLIC MEETINGS ETCETERA.
AND EXCEL FILE IT FINALIZING
THAT DOCUMENT IS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL- IN IN BEING ABLE TO
DEVELOP ON THE DETAIL THAT.
AMANDA HAS TALKED ABOUT ON THAT
SO CRITICAL IN PROVIDING YOU HOW
TO ACTUALLY REACH ON THE
AMBITIOUS GOALS WITHIN THE
PATHWAY DOCUMENT WITHOUT A
DOCUMENT ITSELF IS LIKE SEVENTY
PAGES LONG. AND CONTAINS A LOT
OF DETAIL ON HOW. THE APPROACH
IS TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE- THE GOAL
STATED. OKAY THAT'S UNDERSTOOD-
I APPRECIATE THAT- I THINK THE
QUESTION REMAINS- YOU KNOW WHEN
WILL RE RECEIVE WHAT THE-
VISION. OF THE ADMINISTRATION IS
THAT BASED ON THAT DOCUMENT- SO
THAT WE HAVE SOME SPECIFICITY.
HERE AND CAN INTELLIGENTLY
DISCUSS IT WITH YOU- BUT. EVENT
PERHAPS YOU CAN- OUR FOR OUR
EDIFICATION NOT DOCTOR GOLD
SUMMARIZE- THAT PLAN. WHERE YOU
ARE RIGHT NOW ON. YEAH I PRETTY
MUCH TOOK THE FINAL COMMENTS ON
I THINK HURT THE DEADLINE TO
RECEIVE ANY OF THEM IS BY NEXT
WEEK I'M AND SO I EAT SO
FINALIZING THE PLAN WILL BE
REALLY IMMEDIATELY THEREAFTER
AND THE NEXT AND THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS- BUT BUT THAT DISCUSSIONS
THAT. DAY THE ITEMS THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING UP RIGHT NOW REALLY ARE
THE CRITICAL NEXT STEP. ON WHAT
WHAT WE DIDN'T WANT TO DO IS SEE
AN RNA WAS TO MAKE FUNDING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO SPEND
INTEL THAT PLAN WAS COMPLETED
BECAUSE WE DON'T. KNOW WHAT WE
FELT THAT THIS WAS SUCH A PUBLIC
PROCESS WE DON'T WANT TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WAS INCONSISTENT-
WITH WITH THE PATHWAY- ON OUR
DEVELOPMENT AND SO I'M I'M
TRYING TO FIND OUT I MEAN C'MON
AT DAWN AND MAYBE BRIAN- I DON'T
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE. RECOMMENDATIONS
WITHIN- BY TH END. OF ON. BY
MAYBE. BY APRIL EARLY APRIL WAIT
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS BE FOR THE
STAMP OF USING THE PATH OF
DOCTOR AND MAKE. THE SORTS OF
RED. THIS IS. WITHIN THAT
RESOURCE DEFENSE JEROBOAM WE
WORKING. QUICKLY AS- TO- TO GET
THE REQUEST YOU- THROUGH THE- SO
- YOU KNOW WE CAN'T SAY WE ONE
IT'LL BECOME OUT- BUT WE ARE
WORKING TO GET IT TO YOU AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. OKAY BY ME JUST
ALSO JUMP IN I WOULD. I WOULD
ALSO JUST LIKE THE FLAG THAT WE
DID LAY OUT- OUR SORT OF.
INITIAL THOUGHTS ON. THE GENERAL
WORKSTREAMS AB FOUR. ADS
UTILIZING THESE FUNDS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET IN
JANUARY WE LAID OUT FIVE
DIFFERENT WORKSTREAMS. ADDED FOR
FUNDING AT. THAT AGE BASED.
TAXIS. I WORK. FOR IN. NATURE
BASED. BY THAT BASED ON THE IN
WE RECEIVED ON THE DRY FOR
THIRTY BY THIRTY THE NATIONAL
PLAN AT OUR STRATEGY WE ALSO
LAID OUT FOR. AREAS FOCUS THE
EXTREMES. AB FIVE. AND YOU KNOW. MAYBE A THROUGH THE CORE OF
INPUT THAT READ RECEIVE HONEST
BY THAT I THINK. LATE OUT OF THE
NATIONAL QUITE LIKELY. OKAY I.
ALL THE- IT'S HARD FOR ME TO-
AND HARD FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
EVALUATE AND WEIGH IN ON- I WHAT
I THINK IS OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND ALLOCATION WITHOUT
HAVING AT LEAST. OF COURSE YOU
WANT TO GO WITH US I THINK
THERE'S A GREAT MOTIVATION ON
THE PART OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
GET ON THE SAME PAGE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT WE'VE GOT TO
HAVE THE PAGE BEFORE US SO THAT
WE CAN- SEE IT AND COMMENT ON
THAT AND TO HAVE AN INTELLIGENT
THE- OF CONVERSATION I THINK
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES MAY WANT
TO WEIGH. IN ON THIS- MS RIVAS.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOWN- I HAVE
QUESTIONS ON THE EXTREME HEAT
PROGRAMS AND- THE BUDGET. OF
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING AND I WAS
EXCITED- THAT IT WAS THAT THE
EXTREME HEAT. ARE WAS. IT PART
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS
YEAR. AND YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
AN EXTREME HEAT. ACTION PLAN I
KNOW IT'S A DRAFT RIGHT NOW AND
I'VE DISCUSSED IT- WITH YOUR
AGENCY ALREADY- BUT- ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE
OVER. TWENTY STATE AGENCIES. AND
IN A LONG LIST OF TASKS AND
RECOMMENDED ACTIONS IN THIS.
DRAFT FRAMEWORK. WHICH PROJECTS
WILL BE PRIORITIZED AND HOW WILL
ALL OF THESE AGENCIES COORDINATE
WITH EACH OTHER TO IMPLEMENT
THESE TASKS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION YES- THERE THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF AGENCIES THAT WE WORK
WITH TO DEVELOP AN ACTION PLAN-
WHICH REALLY REFLECTS THE NATURE
OF THIS PARTICULAR CLIMATE
THREAT WHICH I THINK IS YOU KNOW
BETTER THAN MOST BUT- IT'S GOING
TO AFFECT EVERY CALIFORNIA IN
EVERY REGION ACROSS THE STATE-
SO TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
THAT PRIORITIZATION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. WE DO LAY OUT IN
OUR IN OUR ACTION PLAN IN THE
DRAFT EIGHT AREAS OF NEAR TERM
FOCUS AND I WOULD SAY THAT FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE THIS IS HOW WE
WILL PRIORITIZE THE WORK. THAT
WE DO AND THEN TO ANSWER HER
QUESTION AROUND CORONATION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION YOU KNOW OUR
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING REALLY
HARD TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AS THE CRISIS THAT IT IS
AND SO WE WORKED TOGETHER VERY
REGULARLY AT TO IMPLEMENT OUR
OUR OUR- YOU KNOW. MULTIPLE
CLIMATE PLANS TO ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE TARGETS- AND TO THINK
THROUGH YOU KNOW HOW WE CAN
ALIGN AND LEVERAGE OUR OUR WORK
ACROSS AGENCIES AND SO- WE WILL
BE. COORDINATING IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS FOR
FINALIZING THIS ACTION PLAN AND
WILL CONTINUE THAT ORDINATION.
THROUGH OUR IMPLEMENTATION
APPROACH. AND HAVE YOU AYE. LIKE
WHAT KIND OF PROJECT WOULD BE.
IMPACTFUL TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
THIS YEAR. I WOULD POINT AGAIN
TO THOSE AREAS OF NEAR TERM
FOCUS- IT IS IT IS ALSO BECOME
VERY I THINK THOSE WERE IN
ADDITION TO REFLECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES
THOSE WERE BUILT OUT BASED ON
WHAT WE HEARD FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING THE
ACTING AND- SO- YEAH. THOSE WILL
BE AT OUR OUR FOCUS IS MOVING
FORWARD. OKAY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT- THANK
YOU- I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON-
CHAIRMAN BLOOMS- COMMENTS- AND-
IN AN ECHO HIS SPIRIT OF
COOPERATION THAT HE'S HE'S-
OFFERING- IN AND JUST SUGGESTS
THAT FOR ALL OF US THIS WEEK WE
CAN ALL GET FOCUSED ON DOING
GOOD GOVERNMENT FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA- IF WE
CAN FIND A WAY TO- ADDRESS THE
SORT OF ON- THERE'S A- BUDGET
YOU KNOW THERE'S A BUDGET
REQUEST. AND HOW MUCH
SPECIFICITY SHOULD BE IN THE
BUDGET REQUEST IS SORT OF A
THERE'S A NORMAL TENSION THERE-
THERE'S ALSO- A NORMAL- TENSION
IN TERMS OF- WANTING TO- AT
LEAST BE ABLE TO GIVE FEEDBACK-
HAS THAT MONEY BECAUSE IT WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS SO IF WE COULD
JUST IDENTIFY. SORT OF WHERE ARE
YOU KNOW PROACTIVELY BEFORE WE
ARE CONSTANTLY IN THE SITUATION
WE COULD IDENTIFY PROACTIVELY
WE'RE WOULD BE THE REPORTS. YOU
KNOW WHERE WHERE DO WE ACTUALLY
NEED TO REPORTS IN TERMS OF THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF
SPENDING THE SAYINGS. OF SO THAT
WE CAN SAY WE CAN HAVE SOME
SENSE OF CERTAINTY HATER REPORTS
GOING TO BE AT THIS POINT TIME
OR THAT PART TIME- BECAUSE WE DO
PRETTY CONSISTENTLY HERE. YOU
KNOW WE CAN'T SAY WHEN THAT
REPORTS GOING TO BE READY- AND
THAT MAKES A GROUP MADE IT JUST
MAKES IT DIFFICULT SO IT'S NOT
AN ATTEMPT. TO TRY TO CREATE-
CREATE MORE TENSION EDITORS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE SOME SOME-
YOU KNOW SOME TENSION THERE. BUT
IT'S REALLY A AN OFFER TO SAY WE
CAN. WE CAN GIVE FEEDBACK TO THE
ADMINISTRATION BETTER IF WE HAVE
THAT AND WE CAN GO BACK AND-
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION EVERYBODY IS
EXCITED ABOUT THE THIRTY. TO
THIRTY PROPOSITION THAT IS OUT
THERE- BUT IF WE'RE SHOOTING
BLANKS AND TALKING ABOUT IT WE
CAN'T REALLY HELP THE
ADMINISTRATION AS MUCH AS WE
COULD. IF THAT WASN'T THE CASE
SO- THAT WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
THAT AND TEN VERY VERY QUICKLY
I JUST LIKE TO OFFER MY INPUT IN
TERMS OF. WHEN IT COMES TO THE-
THE NATURE BASED- FUNDING- THE
NATURE SET ASIDE FUNDING THAT WE
HAVE THERE- THE- I THINK WE GET
TREMENDOUS BANG FOR OUR BUCK
EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT A LOT OF
LAND SCHOOL. ACREAGE WE GET
TREMENDOUS BANG FOR A BUCK WITH
WITH WETLANDS INVESTMENTS WESSEL
WETLANDS RESTORATION AND WITH
MARINE SANCTUARIES. AND SO I
JUST LIKE TO RAISE MY VOICE TO
SUGGEST THOSE ARE THOSE ARE.
HIGH VALUE INVESTMENTS THAT WE
CAN MAKE AS WE MOVE FORWARD- AND
THEN- ONE OTHER- ON THE SEA
LEVEL RISE. IF WE COULD HAVE-
THE REPRESENTATIVE AND JUST LIKE
TO ASK THIS QUESTION SHE SHE
MENTIONED. HOW LITTLE MONEY WE
HAVE RELATIVE TO THE NEED OUT
THERE. BUT IT WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL IF WE HAVE AN
IDENTIFICATION OF. WHAT ARE THE
MAJOR AND SIGNIFICANT SEA LEVEL
RISE. ISSUES THAT WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING WHAT KIND OF FUNDING
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT- IN IN
TERMS OF. WHAT REMAINS YOU KNOW
IF WE CAN IDENTIFY HATE LOOK AT
THESE THINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
IN THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS. THE
NEXT THIRTY YEARS BASED ON OUR
PROJECTIONS ARE FIFTY YEARS. AND
SO WE AT LEAST GET THE LISTINGS
IDENTIFIED IN. I WOULD BE
WILLING TO SET SOME MONEY ASIDE.
FOR THAT IDENTIFICATION SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE A HEALTHY
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. I SURE SOMEONE
OR- OF GO AHEAD OF. RIGHT YOU SO
MUCH- YEAH A LOT A LOT DO SO
WITH ME- BUT I THINK I THINK
I'VE GOT I THINK I'VE GOT THE
MALL COP TO SOME MEMBER BAND. ON
SO THE CEILING RISE SO SAW ON A
YOUR IN YOUR CLASS SOMETHING TO
WERE WORD THAT'S ALL THAT'S A
TOP PRIORITY FOR THE US INTO CAL
. WE BEEN DOING THAT FOR A LONG
TIME AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DO IT ON. USING IT WORKING
WITH LITERALLY THE TOP
SCIENTISTS I'M ON THE WEST COAST
ON A RELATED TO THE ISSUE SO
STRONG I FEEL VERY VERY GOOD
ABOUT THAT I'M YOUR COMMENT ON
WETLANDS AND ASHMAN SANCTUARIES
I COULD AGREE WITH YOU MORE ON
TO HUGE PRIORITIES FOR US. I'M
NOT A RESOURCES AGENCY-
SECRETARY PROFILE- I'D SENT A
LETTER OUT A WEEK AGO-
SUPPORTING THE CHUMASH HERITAGE
NATIONALLY SANCTUARY- AND WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO WORK. WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THAT AND
AS WELL AS TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
NATIONAL MEANS SANCTUARIES ARE
REALLY PROVIDING MORE
CONSERVATION BENEFIT AS PART OF
THIRTY BY THIRTY SO THAT'S
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY AT A TOP PRIORITY AND
IS HIGHLIGHTED ON IN THE PATHWAY
DOCUMENT. FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY.
I'M THEY'RE NOT THE PER CANCER-
BUT FOLLOWING ON YOUR IN SCHOOL
. AND AN YOUR QUESTION AS WELL.
A LEAST TOPICAL RIGHT SO IT'S
NOT GIVING YOU MAY WITHOUT
GIVING YOU STATE WHICH KNOW IS
WHAT REQUIRE. BUT BY. HEY I DO
WANT TO AND UPON YOU THE BILL A
GOOD DEAL FROM STANDPOINT OF THE
SORT OF. THAT WILL BE FOR AND-
THAT THAT YOU'LL A LOT MORE DE.
ON IN THE WEEKS AHEAD. AND SO
THIS IS- IF YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION ON FOREST
DESERT OAK WHAT LET WOODLAND
RIPARIAN RESTORATION RANGELAND.
GRASS GRAZING LAND GRASSLAND
PROTECTION ON THE PROJECTS THAT
EXPAND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
NATURE PROTECT BIODIVERSITY AND
DELIVER CLIMATE BENEFITS ARE
MULTI. BENEFITS APPROACH ON TO
REALLY PROTECT DANG AND I'M
GETTING THE MOST FROM A
CONSERVATION BASIS OF OUR BOTH
ARE NATURAL AND ARE WORKING
LANDS THAT'S A BIG PRIORITY.
CATALYZING REGIONAL ACTION PURE
EXPANDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND CAPACITY BUILDING. YOU GOT
TO DO CONSERVATION FROM A LOCAL
BASIS AND FROM THE STATE BASIS
AND SO WORKING WITH THE LOCALS
AND PROVIDING THAT. ASSISTANCE
IN CAP CAPACITY BUILDING IS
CRITICAL INCREASING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES TO CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS AND LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AND TRIBAL
CONSERVATION COURSE. ON AN
EXPANDING ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY
THAT THAT'S PART OF THIS AS
WELL. PARTNERING WITH THEIR NAME
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES TO IMPLEMENT SHARED
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS. WE'RE
ALL VERY EXCITED ABOUT POTENTIAL
FOR CALL MANAGEMENT AS PART OF
THIRTY BY THIRTY AS WELL. I'M
AND THEN FINALLY SUPPORTING
ADDITIONAL STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS
TO DRIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
NATIONAL WORKING LANSING CLIMATE
STRATEGY AND PATHWAYS THAT
THIRTY BY THIRTY DOCUMENTS SO
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT AT LENGTH.
BUT HOPEFULLY THAT WILL IS A
LITTLE MORE INFORMATION I KNOW
IT'S NOT AS COMPLETE AS YOU WANT
ONE DOLLAR AMOUNTS AND
EVERYTHING. THOSE ARE THE
CATEGORIES IN WHICH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IF I COULD FOLLOW. YOUR DISCOVERED WITH. AT THE
END I APPRECIATE THE WITH THREE
TO YOUR YOUR FOR COM ABOUT YOUR
- YOU A- IN YOUR CAR. TRY TO
VOTE. TO INVEST SUCCESS. IS
THERE SOME. OF REAP YOUR TO BE.
ANSWERS KIND OF IDENTIFY. OF
WHAT MAJOR RISK ARE OUT THERE IN
FRONT OF US WITH A MAJOR. SORT
OF DOLLAR FIGURE KIND OF COST
ARE ANYTHING LIKE THAT. THIS IS
SHE LEVEL RISE I ON ON THE
AMOUNT ON FOR THE ENTIRE CITY
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS NOT BEEN
DONE AT THIS POINT THERE'S BEEN
SPECIFIC STUDIES HAVE BEEN DONE
ON VULNERABILITY ON OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM- CALTRANS
IS UNDERTAKEN I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE NUMBER OF TIME AHEAD BUT
IT'S INCREDIBLY LARGE I'M ALSO
STAMPED AS KOBE B. CDC AND
OTHERS AS DONE ON SOME ARE SORT
OF WORK. BUT THERE HASN'T BEEN A
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY FOR THE
WHOLE STATE JERRY IS THERE A
LIST OF IS THERE JUST A LIST OF
WHAT THE PROJECTS ARE WHETHER
THERE'S. A DOLLAR AMOUNT
ASSOCIATED OR NOT. FONG WE CAN
YOU SUCH A LESS THAT- IT IS NOT
BILLION PENSION UP AT THE POINT
. I'M OTHER THAN THE FACT IT'S
LITERALLY IN OUR STREETS PLAN
AND EVERYTHING I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT. IS IN THE STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR CUTS IN OCEANS WHICH WAS
APPROVED TWO YEARS AGO. SO IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE THAT STEPHENS
SAID RATHER PUSH IT THANK YOU.
YOU GOT IT. MR FONG. I THINK
RICHARD BLUM A MY QUESTION A I
DON'T BELIEVE IN THE- I DO WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW FROM A- STANDPOINT
- YOU KNOW WHO'S INVOLVED IN AND
DRAFTING- THESE PROPOSALS WHO
ARE THE MAJOR STAKEHOLDERS- I'VE
SKIMMED THROUGH YOUR SEVENTY
THREE PAGE REPORT. IT'S VERY
BROAD BUT I WONDER IF YOU COULD
JUST GIVE US A FLAVOR OF WHO'S
PARTICIPATING. OKAY WELL I'LL
GET STARTED AND I CAN OUTLINED
LEAST ON THE NATURAL WORKING
LANDS CLIMATE MY STRATEGY IN THE
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN AND
THAT ALL THE END UP TO OTHERS TO
WEIGH IN ON THE OTHER. AS HE
SAID- I THINK I MENTIONED IN MY
REMARKS WE WORKED WITH. AGENCIES
MANY MANY AGENCIES ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION- WHETHER IT WAS
YOU KNOW. YOUR TYPICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL AGENCIES COUNTY PA
CDFA- WE ALSO WORK WITH OPR
NASTY SEAT WE ALSO DID A LOT OF
WORK WITH AGENCIES THAT WE
HAVEN'T TYPICALLY- YOU KNOW
THOUGHT ABOUT OUR NEXUS WITH SO
FOR EXAMPLE THAT DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. CAL STAT- SO
BAD IS IT CETERA. STAKEHOLDERS
IT IS IT IS AN INCREDIBLE
BREATH- ENTITIES THAT WE REACHED
OUT TO DEVELOP. BOTH THE EXTREME
HEAT ACTION PLAN AND THE CLIMATE
SMART LAND STRATEGY- I. I WOULD
I WOULD HESITATE TO TRY TO LIST
THEM ALL HERE BECAUSE I'M
CONCERNED I'LL LEAVE SOMEONE OUT
BUT IT WAS A SIGNIFICANT-
CROSSED REGIONS AND SECTORS OF
CALIFORNIA. IS THERE A LIST
SOMEWHERE I COULD SEE WHERE THE
WHO WHO PARTICIPATED. I'M SURE
WE CAN DEVELOP A LIST OF THOSE
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE- IN THE
WORKSHOPS AND- THE EXTREME HEAT
SORT OF SERIES THAT WE DID SURE
YEAH I'M I'M JUST I'M CURIOUS AS
ONE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
MISSING- FOLKS AT THE ESPECIALLY
OF- IT VOICES THAT NEED TO BE
INVOLVED- I GUESS THE OTHER
DELYLAH LAST QUESTION I GUESS IS
THERE IS A AND A DESIRE FOR MORE
SPECIFICITY I GUESS AS YOU
DEVELOP THE PROPOSAL IN THE
SPRING HOW SPECIFIC DO YOU
ANTICIPATED TO BE. ARE YOU GOING
DOWN AT THE PROJECT LEVEL OR-
WHAT WHAT TYPE OF SPECIFICS EVER
GONNA GET WHEN WE GET YOUR BCP.
SO OUR APPROACH TO BUILDING OUT
THE BCP IT IS TO IDENTIFY
PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES THAT
WILL DELIVER ON. THAT WHAT'S
BEING CALLED OR IN THESE VARIOUS
STRATEGIES AND SO. I THINK. I'LL
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU WANT FURTHER
DETAILS FROM THERE BUT- WE WILL
BE A LINK SPECIFIC PROGRAMS I
DON'T WANT TO GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE
OF A OF A PROJECT. THEY GIVE ME
AN EXAMPLE WHAT A PROJECT YOU'D
WANT TO BE FUNDED. THAT'S IT
WELL UNDER CONSIDERATION I'M ON
I COULD I COULD TALK ABOUT THAT
IN TERMS OF THE COASTAL
RESILIENCE FUNDING- YOU KNOW THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY WE HAVE-
DEVELOPED- MANY NATURE BASED
LARGE SCALE NATURE BASED
PROJECTS OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE.
REALLY A PIPELINE OF PROJECTS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN PLANNING IN
SAN FRANCISCO BAG AND ON THE
ENTIRE COAST OF CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- THAT- YOU KNOW WITH
THAT THIS FUNDING WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT SO THESE
INCLUDE PROJECTS LIKE WITHOUT
BASS HELP ON. A RESTORATION
PROJECT- OR MON BEACH- LOS RETOS
WETLANDS- WE DO LIVING SHORELINE
PROJECTS OYSTER AND EELGRASS
RESTORATION- IN SAN FRANCISCO
BAY IN SAN DIEGO BAY A DUNE
RESTORATION PARTICULARLY. IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO ON THE
COASTAL RESILIENCE SIDE- WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF PROJECTS IN PLAY
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD. WITH
THIS FUNDING NEEDS ARE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE OF- GONE THROUGH SEE
WHAT ARE IN PERMITTING- PHASES
IN IN PLANNING AND DESIGN IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE WANT TO
REACH OUT TO- OTHER COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- AND DEVELOP-
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS AND FOR THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY OUR FOCUS IS
VERY MUCH ON WORKING WITH
NATURE. ON TO ADDRESS C. LEVEL.
RISE THERE OBVIOUSLY- SICKENING
AGAIN- AMOUNTS OF IN YOUR- AT AT
RISK OF SEA LEVEL RISE WHERE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS- ARE NOT-
NECESSARILY THE BEST ANSWER- SO. YOU KNOW BACK ON THAT DOLLAR
FIGURE. THIS THIS BUDGET YEAR
SURE I APPRECIATE- I APPRECIATE
THE SENTIMENT. I GUESS I'M AN
ECHO THAT THIS IS THE BUDGET CAN
WE DO WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
AMOUNTS AND WHAT WE'RE- AND THAT
THEN THAT TYPE OF SPECIFICITY
SO- YOU KNOW. I'M JUST GONNA SAY
YOU CAN'T COME BEFORE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ASK FOR MONEY AND
NOT GIVE US ANY SPECIFICITY- SO
IN TERMS OF LIKE PRIVATIZATION
LIKE WHAT PART WHAT PART IN. A
PRIORITIZE- WERE CAN GOING PER.
WHAT THE STRATEGY IS- WHAT THE
PROGRAM ARE ONE OF THE FUNDED-
THINK THAT'S THE MINIMUM THE WAR
AT FOR NOT NOT AS AN OUT DON'T
THINK WE'RE ANYTHING THAT IS.
ADELINE YEARS SO- I GUESS I
SHARE THE FRUSTRATION BUT I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO SET MORE DETAILS
AT SUIT WE WANT I GUESS WE'RE
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS- DEFINITELY
NEEDED IS MORE SERVICES TO
SPECIFICITY SO AS YOU DEVELOP
YOUR- PROPOSAL- IN THE SPRING- I
WOULD. ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE AS
SPECIFIC AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
WELL- AND I'M GONNA HAVE A
FOLLOW QUESTION FOR YOU- A
MISSILE SO BUT- THE ME JUST ADD
TO THE- I DON'T WANT TO. DEFER
THESE ALLOCATE TO YEAR BUT- ODD
THE NEXT BUDGETS I. BUT WE HAVE
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
THESE THINGS AND THE AMOUNT OF
DETAIL THAT'S APPROPRIATE TO
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE- AND IN ORDER
TO DO THAT. HI I HAVE YOU ALL
KNOW THIS WE HAVE- STAFF THAT
NEEDS TIME TO DO THEIR ANALYSIS
AND REPORT TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THEN WE NEED TO GET IT INTO THE
SCHEDULE AND IT ALL NEEDS TO-
FIT WITHIN. OUR- CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO PASS A BUDGET-
THIS SUMMER SO- LET'S JUST MAKE
SURE WE'RE MOVING FORWARD ON A
SCHEDULE THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY PLEASE- BECAUSE I
REALLY DON'T WANT TO DEFER
ACTION- ON THIS. TOUR OF FUTURE
SUB COMMITTEE THAT I WILL. BE
PART OF- AT SO QUESTION FOR
ACOSTA CONSERVING- HAS TO DO
WITH PARK BEACH SAN GRANT- AND
I THINK- THE BEST WAY I CAN ASK
THIS QUESTION IS- SIMPLY IS THAT
IS THAT CONSIDERED A NATURE
BASED. SOLUTION. I AM I AM NOT
SURE I KNOW THE DETAILS OF THAT
PROJECT I WOULD SAY THAT
SETTLEMENT MANAGEMENT. IT IS A
NATURE BASED SOLUTION- ENSURING
THAT OUR BEACHES AND WETLANDS
ARE NOURISHED WITH. SENTIMENT IS
CRITICAL- YOU KNOW THE
COMBINATION OF SEA LEVEL RISE
WITH REDUCED SEDIMENT SUPPLY. IS
WHAT. THREE EIGHT- THE ROCHA
AND- OF OUR BEACHES AND WETLANDS
SO AS MUCH AS WE CAN DO SO IN
TERMS OF BENEFICIAL USE OF
SETTLEMENT- WHETHER THAT'S
DREDGED SEDIMENT OR SENTIMENT
COMING DOWN OUR WATERSHED
SEDIMENT TRAPPED BEHIND DAMS-
YOU KNOW MATTEL HOW DAM FOR
EXAMPLE- SO. IF YOU ARE WELL.
LET'S JUST PUT THE QUESTION OUT
THERE- FEEL FREE TO TAKE SOME
TIME AFTER THIS HEARING- TO
REPORT BACK TO OUR STAFF BUT I
THINK THAT THERE'S SOME- I DON'T
OF CONCERN IS THE RIGHT WORD
BUT- OF SOME LEVEL OF ANALYSIS
THAT STAFF WOULD LIKE TO DO. ON
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE SO- I'LL
ASK YOU TO BE IN AND TOUCH- WE
JUST SAY. I WOULD JUST SAY
REMEMBER DURABILITY I MEAN AMY
DID A GREAT JOB OF EXPLAINING
THE NEED AND EVERYTHING BUT
DURABILITY IS ALSO COMPLAIN
ABOUT AS WELL SO IF IT'S JUST A-
NO IT CANNOT ON THE DETAILS THE
PROJECT AND- AND- AND OBVIOUSLY
WE'LL LOOK INTO THAT. YOU KNOW
IF IT'S IF IT'S JUST A BEACH
REPLENISHMENT PROJECT THAT'S
GONNA LAST YEAR AND A HALF THAT
THAT'S NOT REALLY A NATURE BASED
SOLUTION THAT'S- THAT'S AN
ECONOMIC SOLUTION. ON INSTEAD OF
JUST. THE FOX IS THERE HAS TO
SOME DEGREE OF DOORBELL THAT. M.
I THANK YOU A- BOTH OF THOSE
RESPONSES- AND I THINK THAT-
THAT. KIND OF DISCUSSION IS WHAT
UNDERLIES WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY IS THE KIND OF
DISCUSSION AND DIALOGUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE HAPPENING BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE- AND
THE ASSEMBLY SO APPRECIATE THAT
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. MORE OF- ABOUT
THESE PLANS ELECTRIC WITH THAT
UNLESS ANYONE ELSE HAS QUESTIONS
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUES NUMBER
TWO AND- WE'LL HEAR FIRST FROM
LIVES OF FROM THE ALEJO ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MUSEUM
GRANT PROGRAM. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS. I'M HELEN
CRISTINA THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO LAST YEAR
THE BUDGET APPROPRIATED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL ENDOWMENT AND I NEVER
HEARD THAT AFTER RESOURCES
AGENCY AND I WAS REALLY TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO MUSEUMS AND
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS AND ADD
YOUR AGENDA MENTIONS OUR
UNDERSTANDING. LEGISLATURE
INTENDED TO HELP ASSIST THE AND
THE CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS THAT-
HAD BEEN HARMED BY KOBE
NINETEEN- SO THE BUDGET
PRIORITIZE TRAINING. THAT HAD
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED BY. WELL
AS- THAT SERVE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY STUDENTS I'M SO WE
DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC COMMENTS
THIS TIME AND WE DO THINK THIS
IS A VERY- HELPFUL INVALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO GET AN UPDATE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE STATUS OF
THOSE FINES- AND- THE PROCESS
THAT THEY'RE USING FOR GETTING
THOSE FIND OUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- THOSE INSTITUTIONS ARE
GETTING THE FUNDS THAT- BUT THEY
WERE EXPECTING IN A TIMELY
MANNER. THANK YOU THANK EARLY
AGREE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM AND- IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'LL BE GETTING SOME ADDITIONAL. DETAIL FROM- MISTER CASH. YEAH
BRIAN DASCHLE NATURAL RESOURCES
- FIRST I JUST WANNA SAY DOING
THINGS LET FAR FOR INCLUDE THE
FACT MILLION MUSEUM GROUNDS THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUDGET. IN FOR
PRIORITY THE FOR MUSIC THEY
SIMPLY SEVERE AFFECTED BY CO
CANISTERS HISTORIC UNDERSTOOD
COMMUNITIES WELL. WE REALLY WE
WERE THE OF THESE FOR FROM AND
SO FAR THIS FISCAL YEAR WE'VE-
DRAFTING GUIDELINES AND REALLY
THEM OUT- FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OCTOBER- WE RECEIVED A LOT OF
COMMENTS BACK- NOT ONLY FROM THE
PUBLIC BUT ALSO FROM OUR BOARD
MEMBERS WE HAVE A COUPLE NEW
BOARD MEMBERS FROMTHE ASSEMBLY.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THEIR
WORK CAN. AND- IN THEIR
COMMENTS- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE CHANGED WHEN WE HELD OUR OUR
BOARD MEETING TO SOLICIT
COMMENTS- FROM THE BOARD IN THE
PUBLIC ON. THE GUIDELINES WAS TO
MODIFY THE DEFINITION OF THE
MUSEUM SO THAT IT WOULD REACH
MORE ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT THESE
FUNDS THAT ARE REALLY NEEDED
COULD BE GOING OUT TO MORE
ORGANIZATIONS- THE- MEETING. IN
NOVEMBER TOLD THE BOARD MEETING
TO RECEIVE PUBLIC COMMENTS- WE
PUT OUT THE FINAL GUIDELINES IN
JANUARY- AND APPROVED BY THE
BOARD I'M CURRENTLY WE'RE
REACHING OUT- I KNOW ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WAS HOW ARE WE
REACHING OUT TO THESE
COMMUNITIES TO HELP THEM. AND
HELP THEM APPLY. RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE. FIVE VERTICAL VIRTUAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WORKSHOPS
THAT WE'RE DOING- WE'VE ALREADY
DONE TO AND THEY'LL BE THREE
MORE NEXT WEEK. SEN- THROUGH THE
HOUSE OF. A COUPLE OF OUR
MEMBERS- WE'RE REACHING OUT TO
NEW- MATTER RECEIVED FUNDING
FROM THIS FOR. AND REACHING OUT
TO- THEY TELL ASSOCIATION
MUSEUMS TO FIND- ADDITIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS- SO THAT THEY CAN
ALSO PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
- NEXT TO- PROPOSALS ARE DUE BY
MARCH ELEVENTH. AND THEN THEY'LL
BE A RUBIO PROCESS BETWEEN MAN
AND- JUNE. AND THEN WE'LL DO
FIELD VISITS BETWEEN JUNE AND
AUGUST AND THEN- FINA
EVALUATIONS WILL HAPPEN IN THE
FALL AND WE SHOULD BE MAKING-
FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
APPROVING RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
FALL. OF THIS YEAR. SO WE- WE DO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FUNDING
AND WE'RE WORKING AS HARD AS WE
CAN. TO ACHIEVE THAT BALANCE IN
GETTING THE FUNDS OUT AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE BUT ALSO- IN
DEVELOPING A PROGRAM MAKING SURE
THAT. WE CAN REACH ALL THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED TO RECEIVE
THIS FUNDING. TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS JUST ONE
QUICK QUESTION COULD COULD YOU
ELABORATE A LITTLE MORE LIKE
YOU'RE SPENDING TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS TRYING TO HIRE
STAFF OF THIS PROGRAM COULD YOU.
ELABORATE ON THAT. WE'VE ALREADY
HIRED WE ALREADY HAVE STAFF FOR
THE PROGRAM AND WE ARE MOVING-
AND THAT AND THEY'VE BEEN HIRED
AND ARE WORKING ON THE PROGRAM
ALREADY. THOSE FUNDS WERE SET
ASIDE FOR FUNDING THE STAFF THAT
WE HAVE WORKING ON THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. GREAT OF THE WILL
TAKE US TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE-
THANK YOU CHAIR CASH OF. ISSUE
THREE IS THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
AN ART INSTALLATION IN PARKS
PROGRAM AND- THE L. A. O. HAVE
ANY COMMENTS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. SURE WE DO- HELEN
CRISTINA GAM AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO FIND ART INSTALLATIONS
IN BOTH STATE AND LOCAL PARKS I
KNOW CRAZINESS THESE ARE
INSTALLATIONS ARE INTENDED TO
REFLECT THE PARKS IS. OF LOCAL
CULTURAL HERITAGE AS WELL AS AN
ACTIVITY TO NATURAL RESOURCES. I
UNDERSTAND YOU THAT MONEY OF THE
FACT THAT THE MAIN FOCUS OF THE
RECEIPT- SUPPORT NEEDS ART AND
SO RATHER THAN REPLACING. AN
OUTDATED EXHIBITS. I ANYTHING
FIVE. VISUAL- KINDS OF- OTHER
OTHER TYPES OF VISUAL- EXHIBITS
AS WELL AS INTO SIGNS IN THIS OF
THINGS. I THINK THIS TIME- I
MEAN COME IN IT REALLY IS THAT
THERE'S NOT LOT OF EACH ON THIS
PROPOSAL PARK HAVEN'T YET
IDENTIFY FOR- THE NUMBER THAT
WOULD BE IN. THE NEW TAPES THAT
INSTALLATION WOULD BE. ON THIS
YEAR IT WOULD TO PARKS VERSUS
LOCAL PARK. AND THIS IS MADE IT
HARD TO A TO WHETHER FIFTY
WEATHER THAT THE OF FUNDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE. I OR
WHETHER WE WOULD LIKE TO.
PRIORITIZEEVERYTHING- WITHIN
THE BUDGET SO- OUR RECORD IS
REALLY JUST. I DEPARTMENT
PROVIDE IMAGES DETAIL ON ITS WE
UNDERSTAND IT DOES INTO TO GO TO
SCHOOL PUBLIC PROCESS TO HELP
INFORM. WE THINK THAT THE- AS
MUCH AS- WITH YOUR HELP OLDER TO
THE COMING THING WE'VE HEARD.
AND THEN- IN THIS HEARING BUT
THEY IT'S- IT'S VERY IT'S VERY I
THINK HE AND VERY HELPFUL FOR
THE LARGEST TO HAVE MUCH DETAIL
POSSIBLE RELIEVE THE DECISION
MAKING. AUSTIN THAT THAT
MINISTERS NOT HAD A CHANCE THAT
IS WHAT. THANK YOU L. A. NEXT TO
WILL. DIRECTOR CAN TERO. TO ADD
. HE CALM OKAY. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BERS MANY IS AMONG
LOOKING THAN DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT PARTS OR AND THANK
YOU THIS OP. TO PRESENT THE
CULTURAL AND IS TO AND BY CHAIN
PROPOSED THE REQUEST YOU KNOW
ONE TIME NON FIFTY DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND FOR A CALL IN OUR
INSTEAD IN PRO TO AND IN. STATE
AND LOCAL STATE PARKS WILL BE
WITH ARE GOING TO SAY SO AS
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AND
NONPROFITS TO DEVELOP ART
INSTALLATIONS AND PROGRAMS AND
PARKS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A OPPORTUNITY TO REFRESH
WE ENVISION AND RE ENTER
REENERGIZE PARKS INTERPRETATION
EDUCATION AND CULTURAL RESOURCES
PROGRAMS- AND- WE SEE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARY OPPORTUNITY. NOW
DOORS FOR ALL INITIATIVE FOCUSES
EFFORTS TO CREATE MEANINGFUL
CONNECTIONS AND GREATER
RELEVANCY TO ALL PEOPLE THROUGH
PARKS CALIFORNIA'S. IN THEIR
PROGRAMS THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
OR INSTALLATION PROGRAM INVEST
IN THE PROGRAMMING OPERATE OUR
STATE AND LOCAL PARKS. TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO IMPROVING PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
RICH HISTORY CULTURAL HERITAGE
AND CERTAINLY MANY OF THE
PRIORITIES AT THE END THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ADDRESSING
THROUGH OTHER PROGRAMS. SUCH AS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND- DESPITE
SUSTAINABILITY AND ADAPTATION TO
THE WORLD THAT WE ARE IT. IN THE
MIDDLE OF ART FEATURES A
PROMINENT PLACE IN PARKS
PROGRAMMING AS A TRUE EXPRESSION
OF CULTURAL ENGAGEMENT AND
NATURAL HISTORY AND
UNDERSTANDING. TOPICS A LITERACY
AROUND ISSUES AS I SAT AROUND
RESILIENCE AND SUSTAINABILITY
CAN ALSO BE EFFECTIVELY.
DELIVERED THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OR TO BUILD. WITH
THE SPECTRUM OF PARTNERS
INCLUDING TRIBAL NATIONS TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
PEOPLE TO EXPERIENCE THE
INHERENTLY VALUABLE CULTURAL AND
THAT ARE CORE FUNCTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS. ASIAN
AND SYSTEM. IT IS OUR JOB TO
INTERPRET THE HISTORY AND
CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE OF THESE
TREASURED SPACES IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO TELLING
A THOROUGH AND INCLUSIVE A
COMPLETE HISTORY OF THE STATE
PROVIDED A MORE INCLUSIVE
NARRATION CAN BE ACHIEVED IN THE
RECRUITMENT OF ARTISTS AND THE
REQUISITION OF ART THAT MORE
ACCURATELY AFFECT A REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S RICH CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL HERITAGE WE WILL
RECRUIT PARTNERSHIPS WITH
LEADING ARTISTS WRITERS
HISTORIANS AND SCIENTISTS TO
JOIN IN OUR EFFORTS ACROSS THE
STATE IN THIS ENDEAVOR. A RECENT
EXAMPLE INCLUDES THE OPENING OF
A NEW PUBLIC GATHERING AREA AT
OLD TOWN SAN DIEGO STATE
HISTORIC PARK. ANDTHAT NEW AREA
IS CALLED REPAY T. PICA MAY MOVE
A CLOCK WHICH TRANSLATES FROM
KUWAIT TO ENGLISH AS THE LAND OF
THE FIRST PEOPLE. STATE PARKS
WORK WITH KHAMENEI'S ELDERS AND
ARTISTS TO DEVELOP EXHIBITS AND
ART INSTALLATIONS WHICH HONOR
THE CULTURE OF THE COMING. AND
THEIR INTERNAL RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE SAN DIEGO RIVER AND OLD TOWN
SAN DIEGO. AT LOS ANGELES STATE
HISTORIC PARK THE PUBLIC ART AND
MONUMENTS PROGRAM CONTAINS
ARTWORKS THAT LIVE IN THE PARK
YEAR ROUND TO ENGAGE THE PUBLIC
IN THE CULTURAL HERITAGE OF LOS
ANGELES. AND THE HISTORY OF THAT
REGION. THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
CONSIDER OF THIS REQUEST BOTH
MYSELF AND MY STAFF DR LESLIE
HARTZELL ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
SPEC SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. IT ALSO LIKE
TO SAY THAT THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMMES ON HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
ISSUES SUCH AS THE GOALS OF
THIRTY BY THIRTY CLIMATE CHANGE
ACCESS AND AGAIN ALL OF THIS
REALLY IS ABOUT ENGAGING THE
PUBLIC FULLY. NOT ONLY IN THEIR
LOCAL AND STATE PARKS BUT ALSO
IN THE ISSUES THAT WE AS A STATE
FACE. IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WHAT DOES- THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE HAVE ANY.
COMMENTS TO ADD. A GOOD MORNING
CHAIR THIS IS GUSTAVO MEDRANO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY FORMAL
PRESENTATION BEFORE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I CERTAINLY AGREE THAT-
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
OPPORTUNITY- AND THAT'S AS FAR
AS I KNOW FIRST- FOR RECREATION
PARKS WHICH LEADS ME TO MY-
FIRST QUESTION AND I WANT TO BE
AS SENSITIVE AS POSSIBLE HERE-
IN ASKING THE QUESTION- BUT- THE
FUNDING. OF ART INSTALLATIONS OR
THE- OF DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF ART
INSTALLATIONS. DOESN'T STRIKE ME
AS BEING AN CANADA IN THE WHEEL
HOUSE OF UP A STATE PARKS AND WE
HAVE AN ARTS COUNCIL THAT YOU
KNOW. THIS IS THIS IS WHAT THEY
DO SO- I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND-
A- YOU KNOW WHY WHY WERE- BEING
ENCOURAGED TO ADOPT THIS
PROPOSAL AS IT'S STRUCTURED- AND
YOU KNOW PERHAPS I'M MISSING
SOMETHING IN THE ARTS COUNCIL
ACTUALLY IS INVOLVED IN THIS. IF
I COULD ANSWER THAT A GERMAN
BLOOM SEVEN OKAY ARMAND THE- GUN
SO I JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT DOES INTEND TO
PARTNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL AS WE DEVELOP AND
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM. GIVEN
THE ICONIC LANDSCAPE AND
CULTURAL SITES AND PARKS AND OUR
FOCUS ON INTERPRETATION HISTORIC
STORYTELLING AND CULTURAL
RELEVANCY OF PARKS- CALIFORNIA'S
PARKS THERE'S ALREADY A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND CULTURAL
RELEVANCY WORK UNDERWAY AT STATE
PARKS. DID MR SHIN- HERE FEELS
THAT IT'S APPROPRIATE TO HOUSE
THE PROGRAM AT THE STATE PARKS
THE PARTNERSHIP WOULD BE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE STRENGTHS OF
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS AND THIS
PROGRAM CREATES A FORCE
MULTIPLIER FOR BOTH ACCESS AND
CULTURAL RELEVANCY. X.
REPRESENTS THE AND HIS IS THAT
COMMUNITY. ARE THERE LOW. AT A
COLLABORATION ON ON THIS
ENDEAVOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS CULTURE WILL CERTAINLY BE A
BENEFIT FOR BOTH OF US IN- AND
LEADING THIS EFFORT. WE EXPECT
THAT- THE GUIDANCE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL WITH
THERE ARE PROGRAMS IN- CULTURAL
DISTRICTS- A ON THEIR CREATIVE
CORE PROGRAM WILL REALLY HELP
INFORM THE DISTRIBUTION OF GRANT
FUNDS SPECIFICALLY TO LOCAL
PARKS FOR INSTANCE. OKAY WILL OF
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION- I THINK
THAT- SOME OF THAT WAS NOT KNOWN
TO OUR STAFF WHICH IS YOU KNOW
KIND OF ONE OF THE ISSUES SO
IT'S BECOMING A THEME A HUB IN
THE- IN IN OUR HEARING TODAY BUT
WE DO HAVE TIME TO- OF- TO
DISCUSS THIS MORE SO THAT'S A
GOOD THING AND I'M- GLAD TO HEAR
THAT THE ARTS COUNCIL. IN SOME
FASHION IS GOING TO BE
PARTNERING. WITH PARKS IT SOUNDS
VERY APPROPRIATE TO MAKE- IS
THERE CURRENTLY A PLAN FOR
ALLOCATING A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO LOCAL PARKS VERSUS
STATE PARKS. I'M I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT IF I MAY UM. WE
WERE LOOKING AT THIS IN TERMS
OF- COMMUTING CASEMENT AS
DRIVING THE PROCESS FOR
DETERMINING THE SPECIFIC AMOUNT
OF FUNDS THAT WOULD BE ALLOCATED
I GOT BETWEEN STATE PARK-
PROJECTS AND LOCAL PARKS ON THAT
WILL HELP INFORM EXACTLY HOW
MUCH MONEY SO AT THIS POINT
THOUGH I- AND THE DISSIPATING
FROM OUR ANALYSIS OF THE MAXIMUM
SIZE FOR LOCAL PARK GRAMS. AS I
SAID WILL BE DETERMINED TO THE
COMMUNICATION PROCESS BUT BASED
ON OUR EXPERIENCE IN MY TWENTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AND DURING
EXHIBIT- DEVELOPMENT WITHIN
STATE PARKS ITSELF- WE EXPECT
THE LARGEST GRANT AMOUNT TO BE
ABOUT TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WE WANT TO ENSURE ROBUST
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PROCESS FOR
COMMITTEE BEFORE WE COMMIT TO
THAT. WE'RE ALSO ANTICIPATING TO
ANSWER THE ALEJO'S QUESTION ARE
THAT WE WOULD HAVE APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED ART INSTALLATIONS.
OF THROUGH THIS PROGRAM MOST
WOULD BE- SMALLER DOLLAR GRANTS
THAT WOULD GO TO LOCAL PARKS-
FOR PROJECTS THAT MIGHT BE A
MORE RELATED IS THAT DIRECTOR
HAD MENTIONED TO US. OF OUR-
INSTALLATIONS THAT MIGHT BE A
TEMPORARY NATURE THAT COULD BE-
ARTISTS IN RESIDENCE KIND OF
PROGRAMS- THEY COULD BE A SPOKEN
WORD ABOUT- EVENTS OTHER BRICK
REALLY COMMUNITIES TOGETHER AND
THOSE WOULD BE- SOME OF THE
SMALLER DOLLAR AMOUNTS THAT
WOULD REALLY HELP BUILD WITH THE
LOCAL CARE PROGRAMS WE ALREADY
DO FIND THE CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF. OF WORK TO BUILD AND ENHANCE
LOCAL PARKS AND THIS WOULD BE A
WAY TO ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY EVEN
FURTHER NOT JUST WITH THE
CREATION OF THOSE PARKS AND
IMPROVEMENTS IN THOSE PARTS ARE
REALLY BRINGING COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER THROUGH THIS MEDIA ON A
LARGER DOLLAR AMOUNTS OF. WOULD
BE- OR SOME OF THE MORE. PART
ART IN. WERE THE THOSE WITH- BE
FOCUSED MORE STATE PARKS WHERE
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
THOSE INTO THE FUTURE- SO THAT
THEY CAN BE. SUSTAINED AND- IF
AND MAINTAIN BASICALLY. I WOULD
LIKE I'D LIKE TO ADD SOMETHING
TO WHAT YOU HAVE JUST SAID
LESLIE THANK YOU AND THAT IS
THAT SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
STATE PARKS HAS SUCCESSFULLY
DELIVERED GRANT FUNDING TO
COMMUNITIES WHICH DEMONSTRATE
THE HIGHEST NEEDS ARM OR LEVELS
OF NEED WHICH IS INDICATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY PLACES
INDEX AND ALSO THE STATEWIDE
COMPREHENSIVE OUTDOOR RECREATION
PLANNER SCORED AND WE USE THOSE
TOOLS TO ADDRESS ON MEET. UNMET
NEEDS FOR LOCAL PARKS IN THIS
CASE ART INSTALLATIONS AND THESE
ARE THE KINDS OF TOOLS THAT WE
WILL BRING TO THE TABLE AS WE
WORK WITH THE ARTS COUNCIL AND
AS I KNOW IS- YOU KNOW THE END
IS I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT JUST
LAST YEAR OUR OFFICE OF GRANTS
TO LOCAL SERVICES- IT MADE
DECISIONS ON FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF INVESTMENTS IN
UNDERSERVED PARK POOR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND THOSE FUNDS WITH ITS
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT ACTUALLY
HAVE CREATED ARE GOING TO CREATE
FIFTY NEW PARKS IN COMMUNITIES
THAT DO NOT HAVE EASY ACCESS TO
OUTDOOR AREAS AND WILL ALSO-
HELP FIND- HI. A HUNDRED AND
TWELVE- OR SIXTY TWO RATHER STAY
PARK- LOCAL PARKS WHO. AND SO I
THINK THAT THE PART BE STATE
PARKS IN THE ARTS COUNCIL IN THE
COMING YEAR I WILL BE VERY
POWERFUL IN BRINGING. MUCH
NEEDED MESSAGING AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT OF ACROSS THE STATE-
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT DURING THIS. PANDEMIC ALL
OF THESE PUBLIC SPACES HAVE SEEN
UNPRECEDENTED VISITATION DEMAND
AND SO I THINK THAT WE I KNOW
THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IN PARTNERSHIP WITH.
THE ARTS COUNCIL OF AND OTHER
COMMUNITY GROUPS TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE DELIVERING
ESSENTIAL MESSAGES ON EVERYTHING
FROM HOW YOU DEAL WITH HEAT
EVENTS AND- IN OTHER. WORDS THAT
WE ARE ALL DOING THE TATE TO
IMPROVE A CALIFORNIA. AND MAKE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA FOR A
LONG. THANK YOU ARAMBULA OF THE
THINGS I LEARNED TO- IN- ALMOST
FOURTEEN YEARS OF SERVICE- AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT- WHERE I HAD
THE GOOD FORTUNE TO BE ABLE TO
FIND A FAIR AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
ART- IS THAT IT HAS TO BE
MAINTAINED OVER TIME- IF THERE'S
NO FUNDING FOR MAINTENANCE THAT-
ARTWORK AND- A QUICKLY.
DETERIORATE BE DEFACED- AND- NO
LONGER REALLY PROVIDE THE KIND
OF ENJOYMENT THAT WE- AND
INSPIRATION THAT WE EXPECT FROM
OUR- SO- IS THERE GOING TO BE A
PLAN- FOR MAINTAINING. THESE ART
INSTALLATIONS AND- IN THE CASE
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IS
GRANT FUNDING GOING TO INCLUDE-
SOMETHING FOR UPKEEP NOT JUST
FOR THE INSTEAD. OF PRODUCTION
AND INSTALLATION OF THE ART. MY
OUT. GO AHEAD LESLIE. THANK YOU
. I THOUGHT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
ANSWER THAT ONE- YEAH THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE A KEENLY
AWARE OF THAT IT IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED- AND
CERTAINLY THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL- OF WHAT'S VERY
FORTHRIGHT ABOUT THIS CONCERN OF
FOR MAINTENANCE AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK WE WERE DISCUSSING THE
FACT THAT WE'RE PROBABLY GOING
TO HAVE TO BE LOOKING FOR MORE
CREATIVE WAYS TO FIND THE GRANTS
FOR THE LOCAL PARKS. ON WE HAVE
SOME REALLY GREAT MODELS OUT
THERE BOTH AT LOCAL PARKS AND
WHAT'S BEEN DONE AT LA STATE
HISTORIC PARK WHERE COMMUNITY
GROUPS COME TOGETHER AND THEY%
ARE DEVELOPED THERE- ARTISTIC
PROGRAMS AND THEY DO THEIR
INSTALLATIONS AND THEY RUN FOR A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME EONS THEY
ARE CAPTURED IN FILM AND VIDEO
SHARED ON SOCIAL MEDIA- WEBSITES
DEVELOPED AROUND THOSE
COMMUNITY- ART INSTALLATIONS-
WHETHER THEY'RE SPOKEN WORD OR-
CREATIVE INSTALLATIONS HAT POP
UP AROUND IT- THAT ALSO HAVE.
OTHER WAYS TO ENGAGE SO WE'RE
REALLY SEEING THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITIES TO
DEVELOP REALLY CREATIVE WAYS TO
BRING THEM COME TOGETHER HAVE
THESE EXPERIENCES AT THESE PARKS
AND THEN CURATED- MORE THROUGH-
I WOULD SAY A MEDIA PLATFORMS IN
THE LONG RUN EVEN IF THEY ARE
ARE BROUGHT IN AND WE'RE HOPING
TO IT ENGAGES COMMUNITIES LIKE
IF THEY HAVE POETRY PROGRAMS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT THAT THEY-
ARE SUGGESTING THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO DO. THAT OF THOSE COULD
BE THINGS THAT THEY WOULD BUILD
THAT COMMUNITY TIES AND THEN
CARRY ON INTO THE FUTURE THIS.
COULD BE A CATALYST FOR THOSE
KINDS OF ACTIVITIES. THANK YOU.
CAN YOU PROVIDE US WITH AN
UPDATE ON THE FUNDING FROM LAST
YEAR FOR OUTDOOR ACCESS FOR ALL.
AND A PERHAPS YOU CAN INCLUDE-
ANY OTHER SUCCESSES OR
CHALLENGES- THAT YOU EXPERIENCE
IN EXPANDING. ACCESS DURING POPE
IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION. YES WE ALREADY ROLLED
OUT THE FIRST OF THREE PROGRAMS
IN NOVEMBER AND THAT IS
SOMETHING CALLED THE ADVENTURE
PASS WE ARE FOURTH GRADERS CAN
GO ONLINE AND REGISTER FOR A
FREE PASS. IT'S ACTUALLY TO
DIGITAL PASSED THE DEBATE GET
AND IN GIVES FREE ACCESS TO THAT
FOURTH QUARTER AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO NINETEEN PARKS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY SPAN
CALIFORNIA FROM. HUMBLE ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO SAN DIEGO. AND WE'VE
ALREADY HAD I THINK IT'S- ELEVEN
THOUSAND FOURTH GRADERS REGISTER
FOR THE PROGRAM AND GET THEIR
FREE PASSES SORRY WHAT WAS THAT
NUMBER AGAIN. ELEVEN YEAH GREAT
AND UP IN THE PROGRAM IS BEING
ACTIVELY USED- AND SO IT'S A
IT'S A GREAT JUMP START AND WE
DO THINK THAT THIS IS A MODEL
PROGRAM- AND WE'VE ACTUALLY- IN
IN THESE NINETEEN PARKS WE'VE
HIRED AND WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF HIRING OF INTERPRETIVE STAFF
THEY'LL ACTUALLY FOCUS ON THE
DELIVERY AND DEVELOPMENT OF
PROGRAMS- TO THAT DEMOGRAPHIC OF
FAMILIES WITH A FOURTH GRADER
AND- THE OTHER TWO PROGRAMS THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE ROLLING OUT-
THE NEXT PROGRAM IS GONNA ROLL
OUT IS THE SOMETHING CALLED A
LIBRARY PARK PASS. WHICH IS WE
WILL BE DISTRIBUTING PARK PASSES
TO VIRTUALLY ALL THE LIBRARIES
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE STUDENTS CAN
GO TO THE LIBRARY AND CHECK OUT
A PARK PASS FOR A WEEK AND THAT
WILL ALLOW THAT STUDENTS TAKE
THEIR FAMILY TO ANY STATE PARK
FILLED THAT USES THE STATE PARKS
WHERE THERE'S AN ENTRANCE FEE-
TO GET INTO THE PARK FOR FREE
AND THAT PROGRAM IS MODELED
AFTER A PROGRAM- WHICH ACTUALLY
WAS THE MARIN COUNTY A FEW YEARS
AGO OUT WHERE THAT PART PASSED
BECAME. THE THAT LIBRARY PARK
PASS ACCESS WAS THE SECOND MOST
CHECKED OUT ITEM- IN THE COUNTY
LIBRARIES HERE AND ME IN MARIN
AND SO WE DO KNOW OR BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS GONNA BE A REALLY
WONDERFUL ACCESS TO THAT GOAL A
DEMOGRAPHIC AND WE ALSO ARE
WORKING WITH THE STATE LIBRARIAN
AND OUR EXPECTATION AND OUR
EFFORTS REALLY AREN'T PART WITH
LIBRARIES AND LIBRARIANS TO HELP
DELIVER THE MESSAGES AROUND THE
VALUES OF PARKS FOR BOTH MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL BASICALLY SOCIAL
HEALTH SERVICE REALLY I THINK IT
TO BE A VERY POWERFUL IMPACT.
AND AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO ROLL
THAT OUT- I THINK IN EARLY APRIL. AND THEN THE- THE THIRD
PROGRAM THE WE- IMPLEMENTING IS
WITH THE PROBLEMS. THE EDA. N.
RECIPIES. OF SO. SUPPORT AND CAL
. WILL IN THEIR MAILERS RECEDING
INFORMATION THAT IS A LINK WHERE
THEY CAN SIGN UP AND ALSO GET A
FREE PASS IF YOU'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
A NUMBER OF THE- SERVICES FROM-
THIS IS SERVICE DEPARTMENT. AND
THAT PROGRAMS GOING TO BE ROLLED
OUT IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS AND
WE EXPECT THAT THOSE THREE
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY GOING TO HIT
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA.
N. O. ONLY- REALLY A NEW OPEN
THE WORLD TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND I WILL ALSO SAY THAT THIS
YEAR. ALTHOUGH HOW WELL WILL
THIS YEAR WITH THE GRANTS
PROGRAM THROUGH OUR OFFICER
GRANTS LOCAL SERVICES- WHICH
WILL BE ROLLED OUT FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN LOCAL GRANTS. WE'RE DOING
SEVERAL THINGS THAT WE DID
SEVERAL THINGS THERE ONE OF THEM
IS- WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT ALL
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ARE AWARE OF THOSE
PARKS THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED IN
THEIR DISTRICTS BECAUSE OF.
THROUGH THE SPONSONS SIXTY FIVE
EIGHT AND ALSO WE'RE WORKING
WITH- WHEN WE DID THE ROLL OUT
THIS YEAR- IT WAS A PUBLIC
ANNOUNCEMENT THE GOVERNOR FOR
THE- PARTNER JOINING YET THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT AS DID THE
SECRETARY OF RESOURCES AND THE
UNDER. SECRETARY OF RESOURCES WE
ACTUALLY HAD A ZOOM CALL WITH
ALL THE COMMUNITY RECIPIENTS AND
IT WAS REALLY ONE OF THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY EXCHANGES WHERE-
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE RECEIVING
THESE FUNDS LITERALLY N. ARE
EXPRESSING WHAT THAT WAS GOING
TO MEAN TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
YOU LITERALLY TALKED ABOUT THE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IN THE CIRCLE
OF VOTERS APPROVING FUNDS FOR
PROPOSITIONS AND SUCH AND THEN
THAT GOING TO. THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE LEGISLATURE FOR
APPROVAL AND THEN PARKS WORKING
WITH COMMUNITIES TO DELIVER THAT
SUPPORT AND IT WAS REALLY AN
EXTRAORDINARY EXPERIENCE OF
SEEING THE VALUE. OF A COUPLE
THINGS ONE OF THEM THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. AND THE OTHER IS WE
ARE WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE COMMUNITIES KNOW THAT
THESE FUNDS COMING TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING DELIVERED
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE'S EFFORT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S. EFFORTS AND
THROUGH THE STATE PARK SO IT'S A
IT'S A IT'S A MARKETING EFFORT
TO REALLYLET MORE COMMUNITIES
NO CALIFORNIA THAT THE STATE
PARK SYSTEM IS BEARS. AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON ACCESS FOR ALL IN I
AM VERY PROUD OF THE TEAM THAT I
GET TO WORK WITH HIM PARKS AND
CERTAINLY- WITH THE LEGISLATORS
IN YOUR SUPPORT. THOSE PROGRAMS
. GREAT THE- FRANK YOU- IN THE
SPARE OF OUTDOOR ACCESS ALL
WHICH I THINK IS- A GREAT
PROGRAM. IT'S LIKE YOU- OF
MAKING SICK PROGRESS AND- MOVING
FORWARD ON A NUMBER OF FRONTS-
BUT IN IN THE SPIRIT OF- OF-
ACCESS FOR ALL. HAS THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERED A
GRANT PROGRAM TO FUND- OF PLACE
STRUCTURES FOR ALL OF THE
CHILDREN OF ALL ABILITIES- AT
STATE OR LOCAL PARKS. AGAIN THIS
QUESTION IS INFORMED BY MY
EXPERIENCE IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WHERE WE WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH
IN SANTA MONICA TO BE ABLE TO-
FUND THE- OF PLAY PARKS- WITH-
APPARATUS AND- CLIMBING
STRUCTURES AND THE LIKE FOR. ALL
ABILITIES- CHILDREN OF ALL
ABILITIES- AND THEY'VE BEEN.
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL- I'D BE
INTERESTED IN KNOWING IF THERE
IS A- GRANT. PROGRAM- I IF NOT-
IT'S TIME FOR US TO CREATE. WELL
OUR OFFICE OF GRANTS AND LOCAL
SERVICES EVERY YEAR DELIVERS
WORKSHOPS WITH COMMUNITIES TO
GET THEM TO MEET WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO THAT THE PARKS
THAT WE FUND ARE ACTUALLY PARKS
ARE DESCRIBED BY THE COMMUNITIES
AND THEIR NEEDS- I WOULD HAVE TO
LOOK TO OUR- OFFICE OF GRANTS
AND LOCAL SERVICES. MY ALL RIGHT
I WILL HAVE TO FIND OUT BUT MY
ASSUMPTION IS COMMUNITIES HAVE.
I HOPE. HEY DOES THIS REQUEST
BUT WE WILL I'LL HAVE TO FIND
OUT AND GET BACK TO YOU UNLESS
THERE'S SOMEONE- ON MY TEAM WHO
KNOWS THE ANSWER THE SPECIFIC
ANSWER TO THE. SO I WILL GET
BACK TO YOU- CHAIR OKAY GREAT- I
KNOW WE TYPICALLY HAVE A MEETING
WE HAVEN'T HAD ONE. YET THIS
YEAR BUT- WHAT WHEN WE DO
PERHAPS THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
TALK ABOUT AND I. OF A GREATER
DETAIL AS YOU CAN TELL I'M- VERY
INTERESTED IN- SEE IF WE CAN'T
DO SOMETHING THERE. AND I KNOW
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO- YOU'RE
NOT AUTHORIZED TO ASK US FOR
FUNDING RIGHT NOW- BUT- I NOT
I'M AUTHORIZED TO DISCUSS THAT
WITH YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION YOU'RE VERY WELCOME- I
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ON THIS ISSUE I'M SORRY KIND OF
FOG THAT THE MICROPHONE HERE-
GREAT THEN WILL- THANK GOD OUR
PARTICIPANTS ON ISSUE THREE AND
MOVE ON. TO ISSUE FOR- HI THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AS
WELL AND VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE
OTHER ONES THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT- L. A- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO. WEIGH IN ON THIS GIVE
US YOUR THOUGHTS. THE CARE CHAIR
AND BUSINESS UNIT THROW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND SO THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED AS
A HUNDRED MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FIND IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND A HUNDRED
MILLION AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS FOR
COLLEGE THEN- PLUG WELLS AND
DECOMMISSION PATHOLOGY AND-
HOUSE THEN I WOULD USE THE
PROPOSED FUNDING TO HIRE THREE
TYPES SAYS- EXTERNAL CONTRACTORS
TO DO THE WORK FOR THAT. I
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
CONTRACTOR TO MANAGE THE
REMEDIATION PROJECTS BACK AND A
CONTRACTOR TO CONDUCT RESEARCH
ON FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS THE
LANDOWNER FROM- FOR THE OF THAT
THEY'RE THERE TO LOG AND THE
THERE IS A CONTRACT TO PLUG
WELLS AND DECOMMISSION FACILITY
THEY DURING THE ACTUAL. EACH
WORK AND HAVE SEVERAL COMMENTS
REGARDING THE THIRD- VERY WE
RECKON THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
TO PROPOSE. IN CONTEXT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
THIS ACTIVITY AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF INTERIOR LAST ANNOUNCED
CALIFORNIA IS ESTIMATED TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION AND THE STATE
IS LIKELY TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FINDING IN
THE COMING MONTHS AS- MORE
FEDERAL GUIDELINES ARE RELEASED
AB. AND A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE TOTAL AVAILABLE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR WILDER MEDIATION
ACTIVITIES WERE REALLY HELP THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE AND THE
DEGREE TO WHICH ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDING FOR THESE ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
IT'S REALLY A PRIORITY. AND
SECOND IF THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
STILL LIKE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
STATE FIND YOU KNOW WE RECOMMEND
THAT CONSIDERING REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF PROPOSED FUNDING
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR THESE ACTIVITIES.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
CURRENT WALDRON MEDIATION
ACTIVITIES OVERSEEN BY CALDERON. AND IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER THE
DIVISION THE CAPACITY TO. SUCH A
LAW AND STATE ANTI FUNDING
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCE GIVEN
THAT NUMEROUS OTHER
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE-
OVERSIGHT AS- AND GAS INDUSTRY.
AND THE LEGISLATURE WITH LIKE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR-
WON'T ET. THAT LED TO MIGHT TO
CONSIDER BRIDGE TH OF FOR BY
THE GOVERNOR AND TARGETING THE
FINE SPECIFIC LEAD TO. AND ALLOW
INTO WE- ON BY ABA. A LAN. THAT
WE THE- YOU VERIFY CAN WILD LOOK
AND ACCESS TO. AND THE OWNER
BACK. OR Q. AND REDUCE THE
AMOUNT YOU ASK FOR THE KIND OF
THE MATCHING. FUNDS TO MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL FUNDING. AND THIRDLY.
CONSIDERING ALTERNATIVE OF
FUNDING INSTEAD OF FUNDING THESE
ACTIVITIES DURING THE GENERAL
FUND THAT'S PROPOSED LET THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONTINUE FUNDING WALDRON
MEDIATION ACTIVITIES WITH
SPECIFIED IN ADDED THE TEST WELL
GAS AD GEOTHERMAL AND MINISTRY
TO FIND AND THE HAZARDOUS
IDYLLWILD BEATEN AND FIND. THAT
ARE CURRENTLY FUNDING SIMILAR
WORK ON AND DEPENDING ON THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING THE LEGISLATURE
DECIDES TO PERFORATE FOR THE
PERFECT. IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE
CURRENT FUND BALANCE IN THE
SENSE. THAT THAT THAT THAT. I IF
I REMEMBER MAY REQUIRE REPORTING
ON KEEP HER OUT. AND IF THE FIVE
IS APPROVED WE RECOMMEND THE-
ADOPT BILLING REQUIRING THAT
THAT PART TO. REPORT ANNUALLY
THE HAVE BEEN FULLY. ON EXPAND.
NUMBER DATA A REMEDIATED FINE
THE WAR AND WANT TO FIVE BENEFIT
ARE THE ROMAN MEDICLINIC
COMMITTEE. I ADDITIONAL FOR ON
THE COST AND BENEFITS OF THE
WILL REDUCE WORK THAT BY CAL AND
WOOD BE HOW. FOR THE- HERE I'M
DETERMINE WHETHER AND IDEA.
FUNDS FOR THE ACTIVITIES IT'S
WARM IN THE FUTURE. AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR CAR AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE A QUESTIONS AFTER
ALL THE THIRD COMMENT. THANK YOU
ENTER FROM THE- OF. I THINK WE
THE- STATE OIL AND GAS
SUPERVISOR WITH US TODAY MISTER
AND TOOK. I DIDN'T GOOD MORNING
JOURNALISM- COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
CAN HEAR ME OKAY YEP PERFECTLY
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING YES
THIS- PROPOSAL WILL BE FUNDING
TO MITIGATE THE STATE'S A-
POTENTIAL LIABILITY AND HELP
ADVANCE THE CARRIAGE OF THE
EFFORT TO FOCUS ON PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTAL. PROTECTION I
DON'TTHINK THERE'S A HUNDRED
MILLION A PROPOSAL FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
WITH THE AND IT'S JUST A HUNDRED
MILLION BECAUSE YOU'RE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR THAT WOULD BE
ONE TIME FROM GENERAL FUND TO
PLUG AND ABANDON. IN ONE AS WELL
AS IN THE COMMISSION ASSOCIATE
FACILITIES THAT COULD POSE A
DANGER TO LIFE HEALTH WATER
QUALITY WILDLIFE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. IF LEFT UNDER MEDIA
THESE WELLS ARE SOCIAL
ASSOCIATED FACILITIES CAN
CONTAMINATE WATERWAYS SOIL SERVE
AS A SOURCE OF- CLIMBING AIR
POLLUTANTS. THAT CAN PRESENT A
PHYSICAL HAZARD TO PEOPLE
WILDLIFE- THEY MADE LEAGUE OIL
ON THE GROUND- THE JUNCTION
FLUIDS FORMATION INTO NEARBY.
UNDERGROUND SOURCES OF DRINKING
WATER AND SURFACE WATERS AND
ALSO RELEASE METHANE HYDROGEN
SULFIDE AND OTHER GASES. INTO
THE GROUNDWATER AND ATMOSPHERE-
BASED ON THE NUMBERS- PROVIDED
BY CAL JAM. THAT WOULD NO
RESPONSIBLE OPERATOR FOR. UP TO
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED WELLS AND
THE AVERAGE COST IMPLEMENTED
WELLS AND TWO HUNDRED MILLION
WHAT WOULD NOT- COULD BE FULLY
EXPENDED IN MAKING IMPORTANT
IMPACT- IT'S TO NOTE THAT. HIS
OR HER. MOST CREATE- THERE HAS
WASTED ON THE GROUND- AND THE
RISK THROUGH THE STATE BOTH ON
AND OFF. DOES CAN BY AND THEN
LOT THE CANNOT BE READ THE- AND
- WALDRON THE GREENHOUSE GAS AND
- NO MATH WHICH THE SUPER
POLLUTANT. INTO THAT WAS-
THERE'S A- MONEY- TO GAINED FROM
THE FUN WITH MY FOR. OF THE IS
STILL WE'RE STILL PLAN GUIDE FOR
THE PART UNTIL- BUT A FROM.
THIRTY TO NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
UP AS AVAILABLE- BASED ON
INCREASE SPENDING. OUR CURRENT
SPENDING AMOUNTS- RIGHT NOW
WOULD TAKE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
YEARS TO ADDRESS. THE IDENTIFIED
A FIFTY THREE HUNDRED WELLS- AND
THIS IS UP IF WE DON'T DEAL WITH
NOW WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
DECADES LONG PROBLEM. WELL GAS
IS GOING TO CARRYING CALIFORNIA
FOR MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
YEARS AND HE'S FUNDS WOULD BE
FOR. NOT FOR KERN OPERATED
BEFORE WHERE THERE'S NO VIABLE
OPERATOR- OF DESERTION- AND IT'S
BOTH ONSHORE AND OFFSHORE WELLS
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED- HAPPY TO
TAKE. ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
DOES DEPART OF FIVE. HAVE AN
COMMENTS THAT. YES GOOD MORNING
CHAIR THIS IS SANDRA WITH THE
PER TO FIND A- I'M I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT AND YOU KNOW THE
ESTIMATED NEED OF UP TO A
BILLION DOLLARS. ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH UTILIZING A COMBINATION
OF THE GENERAL FUND FEDERAL
FUNDS AND FEE BASED FUNDS- WE
CONSIDER THIS A WISE INVESTMENT
OF AVAILABLE RESOURCES. WITH THE
GENERAL FUND AND FEDERAL FUNDS
BEING VIEWED AS COMPLEMENTARY OF
EACH OTHER AND IMMEDIATELY
ADDRESSES PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES. SO GIVEN THAT-
THE- NUMBER OF WELLS- EXCEEDS
EVEN THE FUNDING THAT- WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE TODAY WHICH
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
THAN- A HAS BEEN ALLOCATED IN
THE PAST. HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE
WHICH WELL AS PLUGGED FIRST. AT
YOUR BLUES WOULD WALK A JOINT
CHECK- WE'VE DONE SOME PULMONARY
. ON BASED ON THE IMMINENT
THREAT TO ENVIRONMENT- NEAR OR
IN WATERWAYS PROXIMITY
RESIDENTS- ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES IDENTIFIED IN THE
CALAVERAS SCREEN- TOOL- THERE IS
ALSO IN THE FEDERAL.
REQUIREMENTS TO REPORT BACK
IDENTIFIED PRIORITIZATION WE
ALSO PLAN TO DO- EXTENSIVE
PUBLIC OUTREACH OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO GET INPUT ON-
PRIORITIZATION SOME LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AVERTED REACHED
OUT LIKE LOS ANGELES IN
CARPINTERIA WHO HAVE LONG. THIS
WELLS OF THE THEY WOULD PREFER
TO BE TAKE. CARE OF SO WOULD
TAKE A LOOK TOURIST PUT AS WELL
. GREAT TO HAVE- I THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE. MISTER BENNETT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TERRY BLOOM-
HI I APPRECIATE- THE CONCEPT OF-
HAVING ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS PARTICULARLY IF WE CAN
LEVERAGE MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS
WITH THAT- I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
L. L. A. POINTING OUT THE-
QUESTIONINGTHE USE OF GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS HERE- IN THIS
SITUATION GIVEN THAT THERE WERE
FACT WE HAVE SO MANY WELLS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN AYE- THAT WE
DON'T. HAVE BEEN ABANDONED THAT
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THE OWNERSHIP
IS- THE OWNER WHO THE OWNERS
ARE- HI SUPPORT THIS SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN OUR EFFORTS BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO- TRIED TO SEE IF
WE SHOULD TRANSITION TO HIGHER
FEES-SO THAT WE CAN MAKE US
MORE SUSTAINABLE EFFORT AND NOT
HAVE IT BE GENERAL FUND
SUPPORTED IN THE FUTURE. AND SO-
A QUESTION THAT I HAVE THIS DOES
THE DEPARTMENT FEEL THAT THEY
COULD SUSTAIN BECAUSE THAT'S ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS FROM LA- WAS
CAN YOU ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN AND-
AND PROPERLY HANDLE THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD AND IF YOU
CAN DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU CAN
SUSTAIN THAT A YEAR IN AND YEAR
OUT IF WERE ABLE TO COME UP WITH
A CORPORATE FUNDING FROM.
CHANGES IT AND HAVING THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE THE POLLUTERS AND WHO
HAVE PROFITED FROM THAT
POLLUTION BE THE ONES WHO ARE
PAYING FOR A MORE APPROPRIATELY
BE THE ONES WHO ARE PAYING FOR
THE- CAPPING OF THE TWELVES AND-
PLUGGING OF VISUALS. IT WAS IT
WOULD WALKING GET. YES THE CHECK
- WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE NUMBER
OF WELLS THAT WE'VE JUST BEEN
RESOURCE CONSTRAINED. IN THE
PAST DECADE WE'VE- PLUS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN WELLS-
BUT WE'VE ONLY HAD. ABOUT A
MILLION DOLLARS SPENDING
AUTHORITY FOR MOST LAST DECADE
IT'S INCREASED THE THREE
MILLION- WITH SB FORTY SEVEN IT
WILL NOW GO TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR- BUT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN STATE CONTRACTING
WORKING WITH. A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WE HAVE UNIQUE
AUTHORITIES OF BOTH SERVICE
ACCESS AND SUBJECT OF.
INFORMATION TO IMPLEMENT THIS A
PART OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS- THE
TEN PERCENT. CAN BE USED FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BOTH
RESEARCH STAFF BEING COST
RECOVERY OUR APPROACH WE WOULD
DO COST RECOVERY EVALUATIONS ON
ALL LEVELS. THIS IS. A RETAIN. I
BELIEVE WE CERTAINLY WOULD. HAVE
THE ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM. OF DID IT IT IS THE
REGISTRATION INTERESTED IN.
MODERN WELL YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO ADVOCATE IN TERMS OF
LEGISLATION- WELL WITHDRAW THAT-
THE BIG GETTING PART OF THAT
QUESTION- I APPRECIATE THAT
CHAIRMAN BLOOMS RECALL QUESTION
ABOUT PRIORITIZATION OF THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IF YOU
HAVE THIS MUCH UNMET NEEDS. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING
MAKE MAXIMUM BAG FOR A BUCK I AM
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A CONTRACTOR
TO CONDUCT THE FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS OF LANDOWNERSHIP-
AND- I WOULD LIKE TO AFTER A
YEAR FIND OUT HOW AFFECTED OF
THAT INVESTMENT OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS. BECAUSE IF
IT MAY BE A GREAT INVESTMENT TO
BE ABLE TO FIND OUT WHO ACTUALLY
HAS TE FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND WE MAY BE ABLE RECOVER. AND
DRAMATICALLY EXPAND OUR EFFORTS
IF WE CAN FIND WAYS TO DO THAT
SO- I WOULD ASK THE DEPARTMENT
CAREFULLY MONITOR THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THAT SPENDING
AND WHAT KIND OF DOLLAR RETURN
WE GET- FOR DOING THE RESEARCH
ON LAND OWNERSHIP AND FINANCIAL
OBLIGATION. AS WE GO FORWARD-
FROM THE- COST BENEFIT A- THAT
YOU REFER TO WOULD ALSO BE
SUBJECT TO BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US. TO LOOK AT- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD- THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION AND AS YOU SAID-
TAKING A HUNDRED YEARS TO PLUG
THESE WELLS JUSTICE IS NOT A
FEASIBLE. SOLUTION TO OFFER TO
THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA- WE
NEED TO FIND A WAY TO- MAKE SURE
WE FIND A REVENUE AND THOSE
PEOPLE AGAIN THAT HAVE- PROFITED
OFF TO PLAY A MAJOR ROLE HERE IN
HELPING US COME UP WITH THE
REVENUE WE NEED TO PLUG LEASE
ABANDONED WELLS. THANK YOU. FOR
MR FONG RICHARD THIS IS ANDREW
ALL WITH BERMAN FINE. I JUST
WANTED IT NOTE THAT- AND WE HAVE
ANOTHER PROPOSAL- IMPLEMENTATION
OF SB FORTY SEVEN. WHICH DOES
INCLUDE SIX POSITIONS AS WELL TO
DO SIMILAR WORK AND WE DO
CONTINUE TO MONITOR- DEPARTMENT
PROGRESS. IN THE EVENT THAT THEY
MIGHT NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
IN THE FUTURE. RIGHT BOB MR FONG
AND I WILL GO BACK TO MR ABOUT.
I THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM- JUST
JUST REAL QUICK CONTEXT- MAYBE
IN THIS QUESTION AS TO- DIRECTOR
CALL JIM- THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME. THE I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
GENERAL FUND HAS BEEN ASKED TO
ASSIST YEARS. IS THE INDUSTRY
THAT THE ENERGY INDUSTRY. PAYS A
HUNDRED PERCENT- FOR REMEDIATION
DO THE FEES AND EVERYTHING THAT
THEY'VE DONE IS THAT CORRECT. NO
THIS NOT BE THE FIRST TIME
STATUS IS APPROPRIATE GENERAL
FUND FOR CLEAN UP- IT INTO THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION- PLATFORM
HOLLY- SOMEONE BEACH I BELIEVE
THEY GET BETWEEN FOUR AND SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN JOURNAL
PLANNED. FOR THEIR LEGACY WELL
ABANDONMENT THAT CYNTHIA
THAILAND'S IN OFFSHORE THREE
MILES OUT OKAY BUT IT BUT I DID
I GUESS THE BROADER POINT IS THE
INDUSTRY DOES. PAY FORD THE
REMEDIATION AS WELL AS- ARE
CURRENTLY OFFERING. WE DO
THROUGH AYE WELL FEES- INTO THE
HEAD WHILE FUND- ARE ARE ONE
MILLION THREE MILLION AND A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
DOES COME FROM INDUSTRY FUNDED.
OF APPROPRIATIONS OKAY THANK YOU
. MISTER BENNETT A FOLLOW UP ON
THAT- BUT THAT IS WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE IN THAT IT'S ONLY
BEEN ABLE TO FUND ELEVEN WELLS A
YEAR- OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS-
ELEVEN WELLS A YEAR WOULD MEAN
IT'LL BE TWO HUNDRED YEARS
BEFORE WE- GET CLOSE TO HAVE. TO
GETTING THERE OR MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED YEARS SO- THAT THERE IS
AN INDUSTRY FUND OUT THERE BUT
IT IS SIMPLY BOTH ITS CAPTAIN
TERMS OF HOW MUCH WE CAN SPEND
EACH YEAR AND IT'S GOT TO TURN
TO HOW MUCH REVENUE. IS COMING
IN AND- I WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT
IS CERTAINLY NEEDS TO BE
INCREASED BUT THE FINAL POINT
THAT I WANTED TO MAKE IT JUST
IT'S A VERY QUICK QUESTION BUT-
WHEN WE PASSED AB EIGHT NINETY
SIX LAST YEAR- THAT WE AUTHORED-
THE- THE DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO MORE APPROPRIATELY.
PUT LIENS ON THE PROPERTY TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T HAVE-
ABANDONED WELLS SAID TO HAVE
WALKED AWAY FROM THE SYSTEM-
OWNERS SHOULD HAVE WALKED AWAY
AND LEFT US WITH THE ABANDONED
WELLS- WE SAID THAT WE WANTED TO
HAVE TO TRY TO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT- HANDLE IT
ADMINISTRATIVELY- WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT- IF THEY COULD AND AS
IF THEY NEEDED TO DO AN ANALYSIS
BEFORE THEY WENT OUTSIDE A NOTE
IN HERE HAT THERE IS ONE
POSITION- THAT YOU'RE REQUESTING
TO DO THE ADMINISTRATION OF THAT
PROGRAM. AND I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO- ASK WAS THERE ANALYSIS DONE
OF TRYING TO DO IT IN. HOUSE
BEFORE THIS REQUEST CAME FORWARD
. I BELIEVE THE- IN THIS IS.
THIS IS A NON PROTECT
PRESENTATION OUT OF A SUMMIT
CHEN. BUT I BELIEVE WE GOT A WAY
TO DO AT A SIMILAR- COST
RECOVERY THAT'S BEEN DONE
EVENTUALLY AGENCIES- AND FOUND
THAT THAT WAS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO GO ABOUT. COLLECTIONS AND
IT WAS COST NEUTRAL WE NEED ONE.
POSITION TO OVERSEE THIS BUT-
THERE'S A COLLECTION AGENCY
THAT. THEY WOULDN'T GET PAID
UNLESS THEY COLLECTED ON THESE
LIENS AND WEEK WE DO HAVE- LEXIS
NEXIS AND WOULD NEED TO GO
THROUGH SOFTWARE EVALUATION SAY.
WHICH SPECIFIC PROPERTIES WOULD
LEAVES BE APPLIED TO- BUT THEN
THE UP THE CONTRACTING IT OUT-
IS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY THAT
THEY GO OUT AND BASICALLY.
ACTION AGENCY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IT DOES SEEM- WITH- THE
FUNDING THAT'S PROPOSED HERE IN
THE POTENTIAL FEDERAL FUNDING-
AND PERHAPS AN ADDITIONAL-
INDUSTRY FUNDING OF THAT- WERE
TO BE. POSSIBLE WE'RE ON THE
PRECIPICE OF- SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE. UP A
SPENT TO CLEAN UP THE AND THE-
CAP THESE- OF OVER FIVE THOUSAND
ABANDONED TO AND POTENTIALLY
ABANDONED WELLS- IT STRIKES ME
THAT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
DO SOME OF THE- EQUITABLE
TRANSITION WORK THAT WE SO OFTEN
TALK ABOUT IN TERMS OF-
PROVIDING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR INDIVIDUALS
IN THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY-
GIVEN A- SHIPS TO OF THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND SO FORTH- DOES THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE A PLAN FOR. A
CREATING A EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES SPECIFICALLY- FOR
THAT COHORT OF WORKERS. YES IT'S
DO WE KNOW THE INCREASED
SPENDING SO FAR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S ONLY- ALEX-
ANNOUNCES ONE POINT ONE BILLION
OF FOUR POINT SEVEN BILLION.
STILL YOU KNOW 75% MORE THAN
THREE A HALF BILLION DOLLARS OF
THE WILL BE AVAILABLE
NATIONALLY- THROUGH THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM PART OF THAT HAS THE
DAVIS BACON REQUIREMENTS A
PREVAILING WAGE. WE PLAN TO WORK
FOR IN OUR CONTRACTS INCLUDE
THEM AS PUBLIC WORKS- WHICH
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR GOOD
PAYING CAREERS THAT ALLOW FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE ENGAGED IN THIS.
SECTOR I MEAN THE PAY SCALE-
WITH OPERATING ENGINEERS
ANYWHERE TO FORTY TO SEVENTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR- WHICH PROVIDE A
LIVING WAGE ANYWHERE CALIFORNIA
AT THAT RATE- AND WE'VE ENGAGE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO BEGIN
THE PROCESS. I'M I'M- WELL I
WANNA MAKE. I AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THESE ARE PREVAILING WAGE
JOBS THAT THE- THAT THEY ARE-
WELL PAYING JOBS- WILL THOSE WHO
ARE EMPLOYED IN THE OIL AND GAS
OUR RECENTLY UNEMPLOYED- THE WHO
WERE IN THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY- BE PRIORITIZED- FOR
THOSE POSITIONS. WE CAN ADD
LANGUAGE IN A CONTRACT
PRIORITIZE THE FORMALLY-
UNEMPLOYED OR LOCAL HIRES- BY
THE DIFFERENT REGIONS THAT WE
CAN INCLUDE THAT LANGUAGE- THE
GOAL OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING IS A
JOBS PROGRAM- WORK OF RECENTLY
LAID OFF WORKERS THIS TYPE OF
WORK- OF. RING HANDS AND VACUUM
TRUCK DRIVERS AND- DEMOLITION
OF- THANKS IN AND SEPARATE
EQUIPMENT IS SIMILAR WORK THAT
HAPPENS- IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
OIL INDUSTRY SO THAT NOTHING
REALLY CAN DO WORK OVER-
ACTIVITIES FOR CURRENT OPERATORS
pAS WELL AS ANY PLUGIN
ABANDONMENT WORK SO IT'S- THE
FOLKS ARE LAID OFF IT'S VERY
SIMILAR. TO WORK TO THAT THAT
TYPE OF- A- DIRECT REAL. WORLD
MEDIATION WORK. GREAT WELL I'VE
LOOK FORWARD TO- IN FACT ALL AT
YOU TO- SHARE- THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE FOR THOSE CONTRACTS- OR
FOR THAT FOR THE FOR THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S RELEVANT TO THAT
ISSUE- IN DETAIL SO THAT- THEY
CAN LOOK IT OVER WITH MORE
SPECIFICITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR RESPONSE ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. ON
THIS ISSUE SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE OUR
FINAL ISSUE. AND- WE HAVE- AND
LA- PRESENTATION ON THAT ISSUE I
BELIEVE. YES THANK YOU CHAIR AT
THIS IS THAT UNITS ROW AT THE
LEGISLATIVE AND FAFELLA. I'M SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
FIFTY ONE PERMANENT POSITIONS
BASED IN OVER THREE YEARS AND
FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE- INCREASING TO
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND TEN POINT
SIX MILLION ON GOING FROM THE
OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FINES. AFTER
DISTRICT OPERATION- FEDERAL
UNDERGROUND GAS STORAGE SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM SUPPORT AND
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT- AND WE
FIND THAT MOST COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSAL ARE REASONABLE BASED ON
WORKLOAD ESTIMATE AND THE NEEDS
OF THE FELT THAT DEREGULATION
AND STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
HOWEVER WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REGARDING TO
COMPONENTS IN PARTICULAR AT THE
FIELD OPERATIONS AND. PROGRAM
SUPPORT. I'M WITH REGARD TO THE
FIELD. COME HOME IN THAT ONE TWO
TWO BUDGET LEGISLATURE NINE
FIELD OPERATIONS POSITION TO BE
PHASED IN OVER THREE YEARS. RATE
THE RATE AT WITNESSING LEAST IN
. AND CALLAHAN HAS CURRENTLY FOR
FOUR OF SENATE AND- THE PUT- THE
PROPOSAL REQUEST TWENTY ADDITION
POSITION YOU ADDRESS SIMILAR
WORKLOADS ADDED. AND BECAUSE
THAT THE V. OF THE IN THE- OF
IMPLEMENTING CURRENT YEAR
FUNDING. I'M KI<c.cyan> FROM OF THE</c>
AND OF THESE NEW. AND WHAT
SONORA AND RECENT FACTIONS WITH
ON- SO IT SEEMS TO BE A
PREMATURE TO APPROVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES A FEEL THAT ACT BEFORE
HOUSE AND- STILL THE PREVIOUSLY
FOR THE AND ANSWER. HOW THESE
NEW READ HAVE A- AB. HE OUT SUCH
AS WITH RIGHT AT THE SIT BACK. I
M. YEAH THAT FACT- WITH REGARD
THE PROGRAM SUPPORT COME. THE
PROPOSED PROVIDE LITTLE
INFORMATION ON HOW THROUGH THIS
- WHEN INCREASE ORGANISED. AND
THAT THE- ADAM AS A THREAT. AND
SPECIFICALLY THE PROPOSAL TO.
IDENTIFY THE GAP IN CURRENT
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT PROCESS AND
THE DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE ADDRESS
. AND IT DOESN'T. EXACTLY THESE
TO THE ADDRESS THE STAFF. AND
READY TO COMPOSE. SACRAMENTO LOT
OF PICTURES DIRECTED THAT TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
CAST THE THEIR WORK AND WITH- I
ADDITIONAL. I RECKON THE LET'S
REJECT THE PER POSITION AND
FUNDING RELATED TO PROGRAM AND
FEEL. AND TECHNICALLY OUR COMMON
WERE HALF TO TAKE A AFTER THE
PANEL CARE THERE COMMON. THANK
YOU- I SHOW DEPARTMENT FINANCE-
SB NEXT ON THIS BUT- THAT'S JUST
OUT OF ORDER I DON'T KNOW WHY-
MR AND TOOK GRAPH- IF YOU WANT
WITH A OF A LET YOU GUYS DECIDE
TO HAVE A WANT TO PER. NORMALLY
WE WOULD HEAR FOR- THE
SUPERVISOR FIRST. YEAH THIS IS
GENERAL OF FINANCE CALLED A AND
SUPERVISOR AND THEN WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO UP UP WILL THANK YOU.
THE ENGINE- THIS- PROPOSE. IS
JUST IN ENFORCEMENT EXISTING LAW
REGULAR. THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
ARE. IMPROVE PUBLIC. AND
IMPLEMENT CHAPTER LEGISLATION-
THERE'S FIFTY ONE POSITIONS
OVERALL OVER THREE YEARS-
AFFECTED WE SEVENTEEN POSITIONS
PER YEAR. YOU'RE ONE OF WOULD BE
SEVENTEEN POSITIONS WHAT WITH
THE PRICE OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. INCREASE YOUR TWO WOULD
BRING UP THE THIRD SEVENTY MORE
POSITIONS. THE THIRTY FOUR
POSITIONS AT SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION. AND YOUR THREE WOULD BE
OFFERED YOU A POSITIONS OF THAT
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION THERE WILL BE AN ON. OF
TEN POINT SIX MILLION. TO THE
OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS FROM THIRTY
FORTY SIX. AGREE MORE CONSISTENT
FEEL PRESENT SO THE FIELD STAFF
OVERSEE. THANK YOU REACH OUR
GOAL 100% SHALL WITNESS OF TESTS
EACH YEAR AND CRITICAL MADE
PORTANTINO SO IF YOU WANNA HEAR
RECOGNITION. AND USC PROJECTS.
IN ADDITION TO THE- OF ALL WELL
GAS AND YOUTH LISA. INCLUDE
FACILITY THANKS I POINTS.
RUSSELL IN A REGULAR THREE YEAR
- YOU. EVER OF ALL CRITICAL AND
DESERVE WELL. THE HELP OF
PROTECT. CALIFORNIA REQUIREMENT
ADDITIONALLY. YOUR C. PRO MIGHT
REVIEW ENSURE. AND AROUND
STORAGE UNDERGROUND DRINKING.
THANK YOU FOR CURRENT GOING
OPERATE INCLUDE ROBUST OVERSIGHT
. YOU'RE RIGHT WORK WITH A
DENTURE AND HAD. ON THEIR
DEVELOPMENT OF AND- OF THE
REMAINING ON EXEMPTIONS REFER.
BILL WILL COMMIT. TO U. S. IT.
RETURNS OF WILL COMPLY WITH THE
STATE DRINKING ACT HI EVERYONE.
ENSURING COMPLIANCE OF NEW
REQUIRE ALSO FOR UNDER STORAGE
FACILITIES ACROSS. OUR PORTION
OF THE- RENTAL INSIDE OR- THE
COMBINED. WILL BE AN ESTIMATE
SEVEN AND A HALF SAID PER BARREL
. INCREASINGLY IN YOUR SYSTEM
THAT'S KERN. FIFTIES CENTS
BARREL OKAY FOR THE FUTURE.
OPENING IN. DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND- THANK YOU I
THINK- MISTER HALL YOUR GO.
BECAUSE THIS. SURE THING YOU
MISTER CHAIR I KNOW THINK THAT
COVERED IT COVERED IT FAIRLY
WELL BUT I THIS IS CAN WITH PRE
I'M- WE THOUGHT IT WAS WORK BUT
JUST FOR OF THE- AND- I. THE
DEPARTMENT IS LAW OF WORK TO DO
WITH YOU I SEE YOUR- AND I AM
ITS CONSIST WITH AND- REVIEWS
AND I. THE CONSERVE IS DONE FOR
THIS PROGRAM. SO ON A MISTER
HALL- FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE THE
L. A. O. RAISES A NUMBER OF
ISSUES BUT- THERE THERE ARE
THERE ARE EXISTING VACANCIES
THAT- THAT NEED TO BE HIRED AND
TRAINED UNDER SUPERVISION THAT
NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED- ARE YOU
SATISFIED THE- OF THOSE THINGS
ARE ALL. IN PLACE AND TO- WHAT
IT IN A IN A POSITION TO- TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS THAT THE
FUNDING INTENDS. YEAH THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVELY
HIRING THIS YEAR AND THERE IS
STILL SOME WORK TO DO. WE FELT
THAT YOU KNOW THE POSITION
REQUEST ITSELF WAS NECESSARY AND
THEY'LL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO- YOU
KNOW BRING DOWN THE BACON C.
RATE WE JUST BEARD THE ACTUAL
POSITION NEED AND THE TIMING IS
A LITTLE BIT. I AM. SEPARATE
THAT WE DO THINK THAT THE PHASED
IN APPROACH OF SEVENTEEN
POSITIONS A YEAR IS ACHIEVABLE
FOR THEM- SO YES THEY THINK THEY
CAN MAKE THEIR- IS THERE DATA
AVAILABLE ON- HOW THE- THE
RECENT POSITIONS HAVE IMPROVED
WITNESSING RIGHTS AND- LEASE
INSPECTIONS. HOWEVER THREE ARE
ARE WE SEEING IMPROVEMENT THERE
ARE REALIZE IT'S STILL PROBABLY
A LITTLE BIT EARLY AND- IT'S NOT
THAT MANY PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
HIGHER BUT- ARE ARE WE SEEING.
DATA THAT SHOWS IMPROVEMENT. YES
I BELIEVE THERE IS ALL ALL
DEFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT I AM
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE DATA IN
FRONT OF ME BUT- I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP UNLESS THEY
HAVE THAT. RIGHT NOW. OUR
PRELIMINARY REVIEW OF WITNESSING
RATES FOR THIS PAST YEAR IS.
PROBABLY EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT-
THERE IS A SIX EIGHT WEEK LAG IN
DATA BECOMING AVAILABLE IN OUR-
IN THE WELLSTAR SYSTEM SO. IF
THEY'RE NOT IT'S NOT FINAL YET
BUT THAT'S OUR PRELIMINARY-
BINDING- WE HAVE GONE THROUGH
AND- COMPLETED. FIFTY HIRINGS
THIS YEAR- ALREADY- HOWEVER
ABOUT 70% OF THOSE ENDED UP
BEING PROMOTIONS WHICH CREATED.
A NEW VACANCIES AND NETWORK TEAM
TO WORK THROUGH. AND ARE NOT
REVIEW RIGHT NOW WE'RE CURRENTLY
ABOUT ELEVEN PERCENT- BASICALLY
SEE RATE- WITH- WITH NEW FOLKS
COMING ON BOARD- AND HERE IN
THE- LAST MONTH THIS MONTH- AND
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WORK. TO
GET THAT NUMBER DOWN LOWER.
THANK YOU YOU MENTIONED- 85% I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE- WHAT
THAT'S OVER. WAS IN REFERENCE
TO. YEAH MICHAEL OF GOAL OF
REACHING HER PERCENT OF THE WITH
- IT WHICH IS A GOALIE NEVER.
BUT WE GOT 285% AS OUR PRIMARY-
PERCENT OF THE SHELL WITNESSING
. I SEE OKAY THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MISTER
BENNETT. THANK YOU- WITH NOT
HAVING THIS INFORMATION VERY FAR
IN ADVANCE I DIDN'T GET A CHANCE
**** QUESTIONS WAS MOSTLY JUST A
TECHNICAL QUESTION ABOUT HOW TO
READ YOUR CHART ON PAGE THIRTY
EIGHT OF YOUR REPORT- DOWN THE
BOTTOM E. IT SAYS OUTCOMES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AT SAYS FIELD
PRESENCE AND TALKS ABOUT
PROJECTED OUTCOMES THAT AT IT
INTO THE CHARGES WORKLOAD MAJOR
FIELD PRESENCE THAT HAS C. Y. B.
Y. B. Y. PLUS ONE DO I PLEDGE TO
BE Y. PLUS THREE AND BEYOND
PLUS. CAN YOU JUST TELL ME WHAT
THOSE WHAT TO SEE WHY MAIN B. Y.
MAIN B. Y. PLUS ONE B. Y. PLUS
TO SERVE SOMEBODY WHO COULD
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FOR ME
PLEASE. SURE THIS IS ANDREW
HOLTZ DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
AM. ON THAT CHART- THE C. WHY
WOULD REPRESENTS CURRENT YEAR-
ACTIVITY IN CURRENT YEAR
RESOURCES- BEGINNING AND
BEGINNING IN BUDGET HERE AN
ONGOING THAT WOULD BE REFLECTING
THE OUTCOMES THAT WOULD BE
ACHIEVED WITH THE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS EACH YEAR. THE THIS IS
WHAT YOU'RE PROJECTING- ONE YEAR
OUT TWO YEARS OUT THREE YEARS
OUT IS THAT WHAT YOU SUGGEST.
CORRECT SO YOU'RE PROJECTING
THAT AND THEN YOU BUT WE DON'T
HAVE ACTUAL. MEASURABLE DATA
FROM THE NEW HIGHER SHARE. IN
TERMS OF THAT THE CORRECT. YEAH
I WOULD SAY IT THAT IS CORRECT
IN A SENSE ALTHOUGH IT THE
BEGINNING OF THE DOCUMENT WE
ALSO HAVE CHARTS THAT SHOW-
EXISTING WORKLOAD METRICS THAT
WOULD ALSO. THEY WOULD BE HERE
YOUR PAST YOUR INFORMATION.
FLOWING UP THROUGH CURRENT YEAR
SO IF YOU TAKE THE TWO CHARTS
TOGETHER- YOU GET ALL OF THAT
ACTIVITY AND THEN IF THE
DEPARTMENT WERE TO COME BACK FOR
A SUBSEQUENT REQUEST ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION WOULD BE IN THAT.
BACKGROUND HISTORY SECTION FOR
WORKLOAD GREAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JUST JUST THIS KIND OF DATA
BE REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK
GOING FORWARD FOR US TO CONTINUE
JUST FIVE POSITIONS THANK. TANK
YOU. MR VICE CHAIR. OF I THINK
YOU JERRY BLUM- MAYBE THIS IS
FOR THE BOMBING OF FINANCE OR-
THE DIRECTOR OF CAL JIM WHAT IS
THE CURRENT- FUNDING LEVEL. OF
THE OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
MEASURE FUND- I MAYBE THIS WAS A
QUESTION THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP AND THE PREVIOUS
TOPIC BUT HAS THAT CAMPING
GROWING- IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS ACCOUNT IS FUNDED BY
FEES. COLLECTED FROM FROM OIL
AND NATURAL GAS PRODUCERS. HI
ALL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SURE I
CAN ASSIST I AM RIGHT NOW THE-
THE FUND ITSELF IS BRINGING.
PROJECTED TO BRING IN A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
AND BUDGET YEAR- WITH
EXPENDITURES ABOUT IN LINE WITH
THAT. FOR DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION ITSELF IT'S ABOUT
NINETY EIGHT MILLION AND
EXPENDITURES. BUT THERE ARE A
FEW OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT SPEND
OUT OF THE FUND AS WELL. AND SO
IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
MILLION IN REVENUE AND A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION AND
EXPENDITURES. BUT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO SET FEEL
LEVELS SUFFICIENT TO COVER
EXPENDITURES EACH YEAR OKAY AND
HAS THAT THE TREND BEEN AS A
GROWN OVER THE- THAT'S A PAST
FIVE YEARS- I DON'T HAVE THE
FIVE YEAR IN FRONT OF ME I CAN
SAY FOR THE THREE YEARS THREE
YEARS TO GET HARMON HAS BEEN HAS
BEEN SPENDING DOWN THEIR FUND
BALANCE A LITTLE BIT- YOU KNOW
TRYING TO MAINTAIN A PRUDENT
RESERVE. BY THAT TIME. BUT YES
IT IT LOOKS LIKE WITH ALL OF
THESE PROPOSALS IF APPROVED. IT
WOULD BE ABOUT A SEVEN AND A
HALF CENT INCREASE PER BARREL ON
THREE PAIRS. TO MAINTAIN THE
FUND BALANCE SAID. SO MY YEAH AN
INCREDIBLE I'M WRONG BUT- TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WAS BORROWED- IN
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND TRANSFERRED
TO THE GENERAL FUND- AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE OF. THE CERTAINLY THE
ANTICIPATED BUDGET IMPACT- IS
THERE AN EFFORT TO REPAY OR PUT
THAT TEN MILLION BACK INTO THE
FUND. SEEING THAT IT'S NOT YOU
THINK THAT THE FUND IS USED TO
DEAL WITH- I TO WELLS AND WELL
ABATEMENT. ABSOLUTELY I'M THAT
THAT TEN MILLION DOLLAR LOAN WAS
ACTUALLY FOR A DIFFERENT FUND
THAT'S THE HAZARDOUS AND IDLE
WELL ABATEMENT FUND OKAY. THAT'S
RIGHT I AM. YEAH AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS. IT WAS BORROWED- IT IS
SCHEDULED TO BE PAID BACK IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. BUT WE
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE FUND
BALANCE THERE AND IF IT'S NEEDED
EARLIER WE CAN TRIGGER THAT LOAN
REPAYMENT OKAY BUT AND I DO
THINK RIGHT IT IS A HAD IT HAS
JUST IDLE AND DESERVE DESERTED
WELL PAYMENT BUT WHY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- IF I IF I CAN ASK.
SINCE IF THIS DOES IT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT SURPLUS THIS YEAR.
I'M YOU KNOW IT WHEN ALL OF
THESE LOANS WERE TRIGGERED- WE
VIEWED ALL OF THESE AS A YOU
KNOW HOW SOON DID WE THINK THAT
THE FUNDS WERE ACTUALLY GOING TO
NEED THE REPAYMENT- I'M- SO FOR
THIS PARTICULAR FUND IT HAD A
SUFFICIENT. FUND BALANCE THAT IT
COULD COVER ITS EXPENDITURES
THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- WE ARE
LOOKING AT THIS SINCE THERE ARE
SO MANY FUNDS THAT HAD LOANED
OUT TO THE GENERAL FUND. THAT WE
YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
REPAYMENTS I AM. EACH YEAR AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THIS YEAR.
OKAY DO THE DIRECTOR- THE
DIRECTOR CAL JAM. I GUESS. IF I
COULD TAKE A STEP BACK-
CERTAINLY IT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED-
THAT- THE FEES COLLECTED FROM
FROM OIL AND GAS PRODUCER'S IS
IT IS. THE PREDOMINANT- SOURCE.
OF THE OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL MR
FUND. I GUESS FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE DO YOU WANT THERE TO
BE AN OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE NUTCRACKER WITH
THE- WELL AS IT MIGHT APPEAR IS
THAT YOU WANT THE FEES AND TAXES
FROM THE ENERGY INDUSTRY BUT YOU
DON'T WANT THE PRODUCT. SO HOW
DO YOU HOW DO YOU FIND IN YOUR
DEPARTMENT. IF YOU DON'T WANT
THE INDUSTRY HERE. YEP
PERSONALLY- THAT'S NOT MY-
PERSPECTIVE OPINION- YEAH THAT'S
BEEN CLEAR THAT THERE IS AN
ANNUAL ASSESSMENT ON PRODUCTION
AND IN THOSE FUNDS GO TOWARDS
OPERATIONS OF THE AGENCY. SO IF
SOMETHING ASSIGNMENT IS THIS
THERE WAS A FURTHER IF WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL IS TO.
ELIMINATE THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY THERE IS NO CULTURE. I
CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS
REGIONAL. WHICH BUT YOU ARE
LIMITED I MEAN YOU ARE THE
REGISTRATION. A POINT OF ORDER
AND CHAIRMAN BLUE ACTIVE I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RECENTLY CHANGE THE
MISSION OF CAL JIM AND LIKE WE
WERE THE ORIGINAL MISSION OF CAL
JIM USED TO BE TO ENCOURAGE THE-
DEVELOPMENT OF- OF. OIL INDUSTRY
TO GAS AND OIL INDUSTRY AND DOES
SO AYE AYES I THINK IT'S A AND
B. DOES THAT LEGISLATION WENT
THROUGH AND WAS PASSED AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY. SPEAKS TO WHAT
IS THE INTENTION OF EVERYBODY
FROM THE GOVERNOR ON DOWN TO THE
SURFACE- AND I WANT TO AGAIN I
WANT TO STIPULATE THAT I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AND AYE I
I'LL I'LL- I WANT TO GET TO THE-
TO THE CRUX OF MY QUESTION OVER
THE POINT IS. THE BCPS THAT SAID
TO THE CASTING DIRECTOR THE YOUR
BCPS ARE FUNDED. THROUGH THE
FEES. AND TAXES- AND- ON THE
INDUSTRY AND IT WAS STATED BY
THE PART OF FINANCE. THAT THERE
ALSO DOING WHERE WE'RE WE'RE
CHARGING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS CHARGING FEES ON
EVERY BARREL OF OIL. THAT GOES
INTO THE OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
MEASURE TO FUND. AND INTO THE
HOUSES IDLE AND DOES VERY WELL
ABATEMENT FUND. THE INDUSTRY IS
PAYING INTO THOSE- INTO THOSE
FUNDS THAT WE ARE ALLOCATING AS
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. SO MY
POINT I GUESS TO THE TO THE TO
THE TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA INTO THIS COMMITTEE IS
THAT THE WHOLE OUR WHOLE
EXERCISE OF ALLOCATING THESE
RESOURCES. TO TO A PLUG I TO
WELLS TO FIND THESE PERMANENT
POSITIONS. COME FROM SOMEWHERE.
IT COMES FROM FEES AND TAXES
PAID FOR BY THE INDUSTRY SO IT'S
A SIMILAR DYNAMIC I'M TRYING TO
EMPHASIZE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CIGARETTE TAX WHEN IT COMES TO
OTHER THINGS IS THAT IF THE
INDUSTRY GOES AWAY THERE IS NO
REVENUE INTO THESE FUNDS. AND SO
THAT'S MY POINT AND I'LL JUST AT
MY LAST QUESTION AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS PATIENTS
IS THAT- TO THE CALCIUM DIRECTOR
IS THAT THE TWENTY POSITIONS
THAT WERE PRESENTED LAST
APPROVED LAST YEAR. I THERE'S A
15% VACANCY RATE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU YOUR
DIVISION WAS KIND ENOUGH TO LOAN
SOME STAFF OUT FOR A COVERT
CONTACT TRACING SO- WITH ALL
THESE STAFFING NEEDS GOING
AROUND THE TO OTHER ACTIVITIES.
IS THERE A NEED. LOOKING AT THE
L. A. ANALYSIS. FOR THESE NEW
PERMANENT POSITIONS. YES THERE
IS A NEED- ART OUR CURRENT
VACANCY RATE IS- JUST BELOW
ELEVEN PERCENT- WE HAVE FILLED-
WE HAVE NINE POSITIONS. THE
LETTER FROM LASHING BCP THAT
HAVE BEEN FILLED WITH TO DO THAT
ARE ARE MAKING EARNS FIVE HIRING
STAGES. BUT WE DID A SUBSTANTIAL
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS TWO YEARS AGO
THE DALLAS FIVE- WITH THE
CURRENT REQUIREMENTS THE- WE
ACTUALLY HAVE HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT POSITIONS TO BE ABLE TO
FILL WHAT'S BEEN ASKED OF THE
AGENCY. A REQUEST IS NEXT OKAY-
WE DON'T RUBIO WE THERE WAS 2%
LAST YEAR AND THIS IS NEXT STEP
THAT- IDENTIFIED IN RESOURCE
NEED THAT WE HAVE. OKAY I
CERTAINLY- WOULD SAY THAT THE L.
A. ON THE TO BE LOOKED AT LITTLE
FURTHER BUT HI PUSH THE CHAIRS
HANDLED THANK. SO ALL- EXERC THE
PRO. OF CHAIR- WE THE WRIST TO
THE PENALTY TO QUESTION- OF THE
VICE CHAIR- WAS WAS POSING WHICH
IS IN FACT- YOU KNOW IN A IN A
COURT OF LAW WE WOULD SAY THAT
CALLS FOR SPECULATION. RIGHT NOW
THE INDUSTRY DOES EXIST- ADDED
SPECULATIVE AS TO WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN IF THE INDUSTRY WERE- TO
VANISH BUT I THINK WHAT DOESN'T
CHANGE IS THE NEED TO- ADDRESS
THESE VERY IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES SO IF THE
INDUSTRY NO LONGER EXISTED FOR
SOME REASON THEN WE CERTAINLY
WOULD WANT TO LOOK ELSEWHERE TO
FUND THOSE VERY. IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES- AND WITH THAT- LET
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM OUR MEMBERS ON
THE THIRTY FIVE NON DISCUSSION
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE ON THE
AGENDA TODAY. MR FONG. I JUST
HAVE- ONE QUICK QUESTION IF THE
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF NATURAL
RESOURCES IS- IS STILL ON THE
LINE- IT IS ONE WEEK SINCE- THE
YOU SAID THAT THE REPORTS ARE
COMING FOR THE LAW FIRE- GROUP
OF. REPORTS WERE FORTUNATE TO I
WAS WONDERING IF THERE WAS AN
UPDATE ON THAT I JUST WANNA TAKE
THE MOMENT TO ASK IF. THEY'RE
READY. THIS IS LIKE ASKING AFTER
RESOURCES AGENCY I'LL CIRCLE
BACK WITH OUR- FOR ST LUKE'S AND
FIND OUT OUT FOR YOU. YOU ARE
WELCOME SO WE WILL NOW BEGIN
WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS- WE'RE
ALLOCATING ONE MINUTE FOR- A
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK.
FOR EACH MEMBER TO SPEAK ABOUT A
TOTAL OF ONE. AT HOME WE WILL
START WITH THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN
THE ROOM AND THEN THAT WILL OPEN
THE PHONE LINES AND REMINDING
YOU THAT THE PHONE NUMBER IS.
1-576-928-9578. SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THEN- YOU'LL NEED THE ACCESS
CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO
SEVEN ONE THREE ONE. FIVE ONE
TWO SEVEN WILL BEGIN WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THE ROOM. SALIM
GO AHEAD SIR. YES SIR
DISTINGUISH MISTER CHAIR
DILUTION HERE ON BEHALF OF- WHEN
MY CLIENTS THE FORTY ACRE
CONSERVATION LEAGUE. NONPROFIT
AFRICAN AMERICAN LAND TRUST THAT
REALLY LAW TO THE INTENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. MULTI BENEFIT
NATURE BASED PROPOSALS THOUGH WE
BELIEVE THE PROGRAM THE PROPOSAL
IS LACKING IN QUITE A BIT OF
DETAIL- AND IT'S NOT A ATTENTIVE
ENOUGH TO I THINK THREE PILLARS
THAT WE THINK OR BELIEVE OVER
LINE WITH THE NATURE BASED-
PROPOSALS. WE BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AS IT DOES BUT SHOULD
ALSO BE REALLY MOVING IN TO
TACKLE THIS CONCEPT OF
RECREATIONAL JUSTICE. IS WELL AS
ECONOMIC JUSTICE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THE BROADER SPECTRUM OF
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'RE GETTING
READY TO UNDERTAKE. UNDER THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY WE'VE WE HAVE
RESPONDED- THROUGH A NUMBER OF
REGULATORY PROCEEDINGS. WHEN V.
IT MINISTRATION TALKS ABOUT AN
OUTDOORS FOR ALL OUR ACCESS FOR
ALL. WE'VE BEEN A BIT CRITICAL-
BUT IT'S WE'VE HAD SOME GOOD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
ACCESS AND PROXIMITY. SHOULD NOT
NECESSARILY BE THE SAME THING-
TO GIVE A VERY BRIEF EXAMPLE
THERE ARE NUMEROUS CALIFORNIANS
I WANT TO FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THAT ARM WOULD.
SOONER GO THROUGH TSA. ARM BE
SUBJECTED TO A PAT DOWN SEARCH
AND FLY OFF SOMEWHERE ON AN
AIRPLANE FOR FIVE HOURS. TO HAVE
A CURATED SORT OF NATURE BASED.
EXPERIENCE BEFORE THEY WOULD GO
OUT TO A FREE. OUR STATE OR
FEDERAL FORSTER OR OR PARK AND-
AND I THINK THAT GOES ON A LONG
ENOUGH TO SAY THAT. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE GOALS OF THIRTY BY
THIRTY IN SOME OF THESE OTHER
THINGS. THERE'S ONE THING THAT
WE DEFINITELY ALL AGREE ON. IT'S
THAT FOSTERING CONNECTIONS TO
NATURE. ARM WILL IMPROVE THE LOT
OR THE BREADTH OF STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
THAT YOU ALL ARE DEBATING NOW.
ASK YOU TO WRAP UP THE
ADMINISTRATION ACKNOWLEDGES IT
WE ACKNOWLEDGE IT WOULD BUT WE
BELIEVE THIS PROPOSAL. FALLS
SHORT IN A FEW WAYS IN AND WE
HAVE SOME IDEAS WILL WILL
DISTRIBUTE SOME LITERATURE TO
THE COMMITTEE. ON HOW TO FIX
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. GOOD
MORNING KEVIN BLUHM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST THANK YOU
FOR THE HEARING AND FOR. DOING
WELL THE CHALLENGES OF THE
REMOTENESS AND ACCELERATED
TIMELINE THIS MORNING OR THIS
YEAR- I WANT YOU TO THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE AS WELL AND
IN PARTICULAR. HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE SCALE OF THE CHALLENGE AND
FEEL THE NEED JUST VASTLY.
EXCEEDS WHAT WAS COMMITTED LAST
SEPTEMBER- FOR VERTICALLY THE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS HAVE A
SIDE. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
MILLIONS OF ACRES OF
CONSERVATION THAT'S CALLED FOR
IN THE PATHWAYS TO THIRTY BY
THIRTY. CLEARLY THAT'S GOING TO
BE A HUGE- TALENT ON A
RELATIVELY QUICK TIGHT TIME
LINE. AND ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE
SCOPING PLAN UPDATE THAT IS
BEING- DEVELOPED OVER THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD RIGHT NOW. IT'S
GONNA HAVE A MUCH MORE ROBUST
DISCUSSION OF THE ROLE OF
NATURAL WORKING LANDS IN THE HAS
IN THE PAST AND THAT'S ALSO
GOING TO CALL FOR. STATE
RESOURCES IF WE REALLY WANT ME
ARE TWENTY THIRTY AND TWENTY
FORTY FIVE GOALS. SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
LOOK AT THE SCALE OF THE
CHALLENGE AND WORK BACKWARDS
FROM WHAT WE. HAVE COMMITTED TO
DOING BY TWENTY THIRTY. DID I
DON'T WHAT READ. WILL TO BE
AVAILABLE BECAUSE I SUSPECT IN
FACT I AM CERTAIN THAT VASTLY
EXCEED WHAT WE HAVE ALREADY
COMMITTED. AND I WILL CLOSE BY
NOTING. THAT CONSERVATION IS A
CAPITAL OUTLAY. THEY PUT US IN
THAT CATEGORY OF EXPENDITURES
THAT ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS MOMENT. AND
I THINK THAT MAY BE AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION AS THE BUDGET IS
COMING TO FRUITION. AND
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR US
THIS YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS- WANT TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR NON DISCUSSION ITEM
RELATED TO THE FUNDING FOR BEACH
SANDRA ROSEN- CONTROL PROGRAM-
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
MINISTRATION STATE PARK FOR IN
THIS FOR THIS IS A PROJECT THAT.
ARE MY CLIENTS EVEN SNEEZE HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH THE STATE ON
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE TO GET TO
THE STAGE FOR CONSTRUCTION. ON
THE STATE FUNDING ALONG WITH
LOCAL FUNDING FROM THE CITY WILL
DRAW DOWN APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. GOVERNMENT FOR THIS
ARMY CORPS PROJECT AND- WE JUST
GREATLY APPRECIATE THIS FUNDING
BEING PUT IN THE BUDGET AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. WILL MOVE THE
PHONE LINES NOW. OPERATOR CAN
YOU HEAR ME. ARE YOU THERE. DO
WE HAVE AN OPERATOR. I KNOW
YOU'RE OUT THERE SOMEWHERE.
MISTER CHAIR HELLO SIR WE DO
HAVE PEOPLE EACH YEAR WHO WISH
TO SPEAK THIS AFTERNOON. OF WE
CAN FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK AND HAVE NOT PRESSED ONE
ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE MIN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WILL NOW GO TO
LINE NINETEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS THIS IS
NIKITA KARATE WITH AND ARE YOU
FEATURED A COMMENT ON THREE
ITEMS ON THE TOPIC OF MITIGATING
THE IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT
ENERGY SUPPORT SOLUTIONS AT THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMUNITY SCALE
FOR INDIVIDUAL HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ITEM BUT YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
CONSIDER AT A FUTURE HEARING
COULD JUST AS A QUICK PREVIEW.
THE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CLOSE
TO ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET FOR DIRECT
INSTALL PROGRAM TARGETED TOWARD
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS TO PROVIDE
EFFICIENT ALL ELECTRIC HEAT
PUMPS FOR COOLING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY IN BUILDING
INFORMATION TO COMPLEMENT THOSE
INVESTMENTS WE ALONG WITH
ARCHIVAL JUSTICE PARTNERS ARE
URGING THE LEGISLATURE TO INVEST
AN ADDITIONAL BILLION DOLLARS
THE CONSTRUCTION OF. AGREED TO
COMMUNITY REBELLION CENTER ON
THE PROGRAM AT THE GROWTH HAS
THAT THE TO ADDRESS THE GROWING
NEED OF WORK CLASS CAN AND FACE
OF CRISES LIKE EXTREME HEAT
WHILE BY POWER OUTAGES NO PUEDEN. CAN WE- THE- TWO HUNDRED NINE
DOLLARS COUPON FOR. FOUR SEVEN
ABANDONED OIL WELLS. BUT FORWARD
TO WORKING THE LARGEST. AND THAT
ARE. CAR ON THE FUNDING. WILL
PLAN TO FOLLOW UP THAT AND WE
APPRECIATE HAVE A NUMBER OF.
BECAUSE ON THE EARLIER. AND
FINALLY AFTER BY THIRTY THE
SUPPORT FUNDING- THAT. TO
CARRYING OUT STRATEGY THE STATE
BY THIRTY PATHWAY REPORT ONCE
YOU HAVE MARCH- DETAILED AND- OF
COURSE. IN FUNDING EXISTING HER
. AT THE DOUBLE C. T. CONSERVING
. A BOLD NEW FOR CAPACITY. FOR
TRIED AND COMMUNITY ARE GONNA.
ALL OF WHOM WILL BE REALLY. TO
ACCOMPLISHING THE GOAL BY
THIRTY. THANK THANK YOU. TONY
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE FOR THE VIRUS FUND AND
THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION.
HOW WE WOULD ALL LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR ITEM ONE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE. AND ARE GLAD
TO SEE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOLLOWING THROUGH ON
INVESTMENTS PROMISED AND IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. AND WE OBVIOUSLY
LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING MORE
DETAILS AS THEY BECOME AVAILABLE
AND ARE. EXCITED TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. FOR ACQUISITIONS- TO
HELP THE STATE MEET IT'S THIRTY
FIVE THIRTY TARGET. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
EARTHJUSTICE COMMENTING IN
REGARDS TO ISSUE FOR ON OIL
WHILE REMEDIATION ABANDONED BACK
I WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S ATTENTION TO THIS
MATTER BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
FUNDING- AND THAT THIS WORK
REALLY MUST FOLLOW THE POLLUTERS
PAYS PRINCIPLE TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE OPERATORS DO
NOT RECEIVE A BAILOUT. HOW
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO FOOT THE BILL FOR THIS
NEEDED WORK. AND WHEN I HIGH
LIGHTEN ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
MR BENNETT REGARDING THE NEED
FOR HIGHER SPEEDS AND BONDING
REQUIREMENTS. I TO RAISE THE
NEEDED FUNDS FOR THIS WORK ALSO
TO DISSENTED THIS INCENTIVIZE.
FURTHER DESERTION WE DON'T WANT
TO CREATE A CYCLE. WHERE
OPERATORS THINK THAT THAT THE
STATE'S GOING TO PICK UP WHEN
THEY- ABANDON AWHILE. AND
LASTLY- SHOULD THE PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BE
APPROPRIATED WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
SEE SOME GUARD RAILS WE HAVE
pOUT IN A LETTER WE SUBMITTED
YESTERDAY THAT SUBCOMMITTEE. I'M
BUT ONE HIGHLIGHT THAT REGARDS
TO PRIORITIZATION. RECOMMEND
REMEDIATION OF ORPHANED WELLS
LOCATED WITHIN AT LEAST THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED FEET OF SENSITIVE
RECEPTORS. AND USING THE
CALAVERAS SCREEN FOR FURTHER
PRIORITIZATION OF THOSE FILES.
THANK YOU AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION. GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. BY. TWENTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
EUROPE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SOLANA BEACH IN SUPPORT OF THE
NON DISCUSSION ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY TO THE BEACH EROSION
CONTROL PROGRAM WE WOULD ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE CITY EVENTS
NEED A DESCRIPTION BY DONOVAN
CLAY AND WHICH IS IMPORTANT THAT
THE FUNDS TO ADDRESS THE EROSION
OF EACH BATTLE HARD BEACHES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NINE THIRTY. LINE. THIRTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING JERRY BERMAN
MEMBERS ANY GOVERNMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION COURSE WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
IN NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
PARTICULARLY THEY INCLUSION OF
FUNDING TO LOCAL COURT FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SUMMARY AND-
TO THE ASSEMBLY TO INCLUDE THAT
PROVISION IN THE PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY SIX.
A GOOD MORNING AGAIN DELFINO
SPEAKING ON THE BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY CAL WILD
FUTURE DOUBLE TRUST IN THE SNOW
MELTING AND TRUST I WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS BY PAUL MASON
REGARDING THE SCOPE AND SCALE
OF- THAT NEED AFFECTED WITH THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PACKAGE- AND
WITH THIRTY BY THIRTY ALONE THE
STATE IS ESTIMATED WE NEEDED
ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION ACRES OF
LAND CONSERVE WITHIN THE NEXT
EIGHT YEARS. AND TO DO THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED MORE AND
DEDICATED FUNDING WE WILL NEED
AT LEAST A BILLION DOLLARS
DIRECTED TOWARDS THE FELLING
THIRTY BY THIRTY SPECIFICALLY
BEING DIRECTED TO THE WCD
COASTAL CONSERVANCY'S AND OTHER
CONSERVANCY CDFW IN PARTICULAR
DEFENDER TEAM CAPTAIN CAL WILD
LIKE TO SEE MONEY DIRECTED TO
THE NEWLY CREATED DESERT
CONSERVATION PROGRAM AT THE W.
C. B. WE ALSO URGE AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DIRECTED TO
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY TO FILL
THE MULTIPLE GOLD THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY EQUITY CLIMATE AND- AND
EQUITY IN CLIMATE- WE WOULD AT
THE- ENERGY FEED COMMENTS
REGARDING CAPACITY BUILDING. A
TO ACCOMPLISH THE STATE'S GOALS
WE'RE GONNA NEED HUGE ENGAGEMENT
FROM PARTNERS AND THEY'RE GOING
TO NEED RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
WE'RE ASKING A LOT OF RCD TRIBE
PLAN TRUCKING COMMUNITY OPAQUE
ORGANIZATIONS AND FINALLY WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT AND DIRECTION AND
INCLUDING ANY FINAL BUDGET
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS A
MECHANISM TO ENSURE THAT THAT
PUBLICLY PUBLICATION OF THE
PATHWAYS REPORT IS THE BEGINNING
AND NOT ADVANCE. SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND REQUIRING ANNUAL
REPORTING ON THE PROGRESS OF
THIS EFFORT AND A CLEAR
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE SO THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO THERE ARE PEOPLE
GETTING UP EVERY DAY WITHIN THE
RESOURCES AGENCY ASKING
THEMSELVES WHAT DO I NEED TO DO
TODAY TO GET CALIFORNIA CLOSER
TO THIRTY BY THIRTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIVE THIRTY. SHARE
SAID SHAUNA IN TIME THE CAL IN
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING FIVE HUNDRED
INDEPENDENT OIL AND GAS
PRODUCERS IN THE STATE AS WELL
AS SERVICE AND SUPPLY COMPANIES
ROYALTY OWNERS WE ARE THE
RESPONSIBLE OIL PRODUCERS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA PRODUCING THE ONLY
CLIMATE COMPLIANT BARREL OF
CRUDE OIL ON THE PLANET NOW WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE SEVENTY FOUR
NEW FULL TIME POSITIONS THE
CALCIUM IS REQUESTING AT AN
ONGOING COST TO PRODUCERS OF
THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR CURRENTLY CAL JIM
HAS A FIFTEEN POINT 63% VACANCY
RATE THAT'S FIFTY THREE FULL
TIME POSITIONS. THEY ALSO HAVE
SIXTY FULL TIME POSITIONS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN THEIR FRACKING
UNIT THEY ARE NOT ISSUING
CRACKING PERMITS THOSE STAFF DO
NOT HAVE A JOB TO DO SO THEY
HAVE A HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
POSITIONS THAT ARE FUNGIBLE
RIGHT NOW FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THAT THEY CAN USE TO RESOLVE
THEIR NEED FOR SEVENTY FOUR
POSITION THE WE STAND OPPOSED TO
THIS DOCUMENTATION WE ARE
ALREADY PAYING ALMOST TEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR THE
AUGMENTATION THEY RECEIVED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS. I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THERE'S A CHRONIC
VACANCY PROBLEM THE CALCIUM THEY
HAVE RUN A 70% VACANCY RATE OVER
THE LAST SEVEN BUDGET CYCLE IT'S
A CHRONIC PROBLEM AND WE'RE
TIRED OF PAYING FOR A SEVENTY
PER 70% VACANCY RATE AT A
DEPARTMENT WE FIND THAT 1100%
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THANK YOU YOUR COMMENT.
WHEN CAN I GO NOW TO LINE THIRTY
FOUR. H. HI GOOD MORNING NO ONE
. GOOD MORNING TO THE DANNO
CONFER WITH THE F. L. E. WE ARE
STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION
AT THE TWENTY SIXTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY EIGHT IN THE
TOWN. CENTER EVERY REVIEW THAT-
DETECTIVE TO GET COUNTY STATE
PROVIDING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
FOR THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE EACH YEAR. HE ABOUT THE
SUPPORT- ISSUE TWO OF THE TOP
WHO CONSERVANCY BUDGET ITEM-
REGARDING EIGHTY EIGHT LIKE
PREVENT. SECOND WE ALL SUPPORT
THE- COMMITTEE QUESTION TO STATE
PARK CALLING FOR FURTHER UPDATES
INVESTMENT TOWARDS OUT THE- FOR
ALL. AND A DISPLAY WITH SUPPORT
COMMITTEE TO DO. TO OTHER. FOR
CREATION OF A GRANT PROGRAM TO
FUND PLAY STRUCTURES CRITICAL
CHILDREN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING-
CHAIR BLOWN IN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BETH PRATT AND I AM- WITH THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION ONE
OF THE OLDEST AND LARGEST
CONSERVATION GROUPS REPRESENTING
SIX MILLION MEMBERS NATIONWIDE I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE REQUEST-
FROM THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY FOR THE TEN MILLION
TOWARDS THE LIBERTY CANYON
WILDLIFE CROSSING PROJECT. AS
YOU KNOW- THE LIBERTY CANYON
PROJECT IS- ABOUT TO GO UNDER
WAY AND SET A MODEL WORLDWIDE
FOR URBAN WILDLIFE CONSERVATION-
ALSO IS GOING TO PROTECT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OUR WILD
HERITAGE OF A VERY THREATEN
MOUNT LINE POPULATION BUT ALSO
DOES MORE THAN THAT IT FITS
REALLY WELL WITH THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY GOALS AND KEPT
RECONNECTING A WHOLE ECOSYSTEM
ECOLOGICALLY AND PRESERVING THE
IMMENSE BIODIVERSITY OF THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS SOUTH I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS I ALSO
WANTED TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO- THINK ARCHER BLOOM FOR HIS
IMMENSE EFFORTS AND NOT LINE
PROTECTION BIODIVERSITY AND
BEING ON SUCH A GREAT SUPPORTER
OF THIS WILDLIFE CROSSING THAT.
LILY IS BREAKING GROUND IN JUST
A COUPLE MONTHS. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND HE A
WILDLIFE CROSSING. ONE THIRTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NATALIE MAC ON BEHALF OF
MY GENERATION CONSERVATION
THIRTY WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ECHO COMMENTS MADE BY BETH PRATT
CAN WE SUPPORT OF EPISODIC
CROSSING ALSO WANTS TO MAKE
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CHANCELLOR WHICH OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT THAT THE RAPIDLY GET
MENTIONED CHRIS COUNTY- WE'RE
MAKING COMMENTS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY PACKAGE WE ARE
GREATLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PACKAGE IN A SPECIALLY WHEN I
CALL OUT OR SUPPORT ENTER
SUPPOSED INVESTMENT FOR COASTAL
PROTECTION. AND ADAPTATION THANK
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FINE.
FORTY GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE HELLO
GONZALEZ BUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THEY WERE GOOD
COMMENTARY AND QUESTIONS RAISED
BY MEMBERS TODAY PARTICULARLY
AROUND THE NEED FOR MORE CLARITY
ON ITEM ONE THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE IN THE NATURE
BASED SATISFIED THERE ARE MANY
CONVERSATION HAPPENING AROUND
THIRTY BY THIRTY IN CALIFORNIA
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD THE
DISCUSSION IN A WAY TO
ADEQUATELY INTEGRATE THAT
OVERALL CLIMATE STRATEGY TO
DEMONSTRATE THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO MEETING THIS VERY
AMBITIOUS GOAL WHICH INVOLVES
CONSERVING SIX MILLION MORE
ACRES THE NEXT EIGHT YEARS. THE
BUDGET MUST HAVE SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED
TO CARRYING OUT THE STRATEGIES
IN THE STATE THIRTY BY THIRTY
PATHWAYS REPORT AS MENTIONED BY
DOCTOR GOLD TODAY INCLUDING
FUNDING TO EXISTING GRANT
PROGRAMS AT THE WCB AND
CONSERVANCY- WE APPRECIATE THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THAT IT
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS WE CAN FEEL THAT
THEY NEED TO CONTINUE AND TO BE
MORE AS MENTIONED BY OUR CALL WE
CAN HELP YOU KNOW- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
ENSURE THAT THE- COMMITMENTS
WILL CONTINUE AND WE REALLY
THINK- CHAPLAIN. FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. BY. FORTY HELLO TURN MEMBERS
OF THE STATE ADVANCEMENT LEADERS
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SPEAKING ON ITEM
ONE FIRSTLY WE DO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO MILLION PROPOSAL IN JANUARY
BUDGET FOR A STATE WIDE LOW
INCOME BUILDING UPGRADE PROGRAM
TO HELP THE MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
FROM EXTREME HEAT WHETHER IN
THEIR OWN HOME. IT IS SHOWING
REQUEST ONE BILLION OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION UPGRADE OF
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE PROTECTION
AT THE NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL FORTY
TO FINISH COMMUNITIES THAT THE
COMPLETE WHAT CAN YOU IS OTHER
PUBLIC AND TO AND COMMUNITY. IN
DINING TABLE OKAY TO CRIME A
CRIME. THE TERM OUT QUITE IS
WHAT STRATEGY BE MOST AND
PROTECT. TO CALIFORNIA'S CONDUCT
SAFETY TO CRY CHANGE. MEETINGS
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA ARE EXTRA
SEVERE EFFECTS SHE- AT THE
MEETING AT THE END OF. AND
SUSTAINED STATE LAW RESILIENCE
STRESS. TO QUITE COOLING
EMERGENCY POWER AND- I'VE NEVER
HAD LEVEL RIGHT RESIDENTS
LISTENING TO CLIMATE. YEAR AFTER
YEAR. FINALLY WE MILLION.
CLINICS HEAT. IN THE PREVIOUS
SHOULD BE DIRECTED ABOUT OF P.
THREE AND THIS YEAR. CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES PRIVATE HARM I
THOUGHT ON THE CAN GET COULD. TO
WITH THE NEED THE SENATE ACROSS
OUR- THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I TWELVE. GOOD MORNING
JERRY COMMITTEE NOW MY IS PARAM
JERRY ON ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
WEST PACK REACH CULTURE AT THE
IS THE LARGE HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN BECAUSE WITH
MOST FOR SPECIES THE
MINISTRATION THE- STAFFORD'S
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE. BUILT ON
REZONING BUT NATURE BASICALLY.
WITH THE HELP OF BATES THEN CPC
. CALIFORNIA CAN EXCEL BECAUSE-
OF COULD HAVE A THAT WE NOT ONLY
. THE BY THE APART TO. AND
NATURAL IT'S QUIT YOUR- IN OUR
RACETRACK THIRTY THIRTY- THAT.
PACKAGE THE BY THIRTY TWO.
RECOGNIZES THE ROLE OF THE C. P.
THEN AT THE PEAK OF THE CAN PLAY
AN- THAT HAD. THESE GOALS AND
IDENTIFIES THE STATE THE
STRATEGIC ACTIONS THE FIRST AND
MOST IMPORTANT WHICH IS TO
EXECUTE STRATEGIC LAND
ACQUISITIONS. WE HAVE THE POLICE
REPORT INCREASE IN ONGOING
FUNDING IN THE STATE BUDGET FOR
LAND ACQUISITION PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT HUNDRED NINETY PACKAGE.
INCLUDING THOSE ADMINISTERED BY
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
WE CAN'T GET THE STATE
CONDITIONS CLIMATE ACTION AND
CONSERVATION GOALS ABOUT IT
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHT NINE. PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT BY MAKING. PARDON ME JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. BY MAKING YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU UP
GOOD MORNING JERRY LAMBERT PASHA
NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS AND THE ASSOCIATION OF
WITH FOR CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
AT THE PRESENTATION OF REPRESENT
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WORKING ON NATURAL RESOURCES
PROTECTION AND RESTORATION PLAN
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE A NATURE BASED
POLLUTION BY THE SIDE- WE WILL
NOT LIKE THE STATE YOU CAN.
INVESTING IN. ORGANIZATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR NONPROFIT AND LOCAL
PARTNERS HI GOOD DAY INCLUDING
THE LAND TRUST ARE YOU THE TRIED
AND THAT'S ARGUMENT. ARE BUT
DICTATE LOCAL EMPLOYMENT PAY
PART AND HE WILL HELP THE STATE
AND SHE IS THIRTY BY THIRTY I
pIN THE- ON THE COURT. WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THE YOU IN BACK A
LOT TERM. AND SAID THAT MATCH
LAND- IT'S MY NEEDED. AND
HISTORICALLY BEEN UNDER. BUT WE
REALLY TO IN FACT IN LOCAL
PAPERS THAT WERE CUT AND PURPOSE
. AND FINAL WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ALTHOUGH THE SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS-
IT'S A LOT OF MY WE PROBABLY
THAT THIS NUMBERS BE. INCREASE
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE. THAT PARTY
BY THE- AND PRIVATE RESILIENT
OKAY THANK AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WITH THE FACT. ON HAS TALKED
ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. FIND SOME. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED MEMBERS MY NAME IS ERIC
HARRISON WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- WHERE STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT PROTECTION ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES DRUG
STATE. I'D LIKE TO FIRST ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE EARLIER BY DAN
OAKLAND FANS OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS IN SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY OF ITEM TO- BUT ALSO
I WANTED TO ECHO HIS COMMENTS
REGARDING THE QUESTION RAISED BY
THE CHAIR- ABOUT OUTDOOR ACCESS
FOR ALL- IT'S A REAL PARTY FOR
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY- AS WE ARE STILL IN-
THE PANDEMIC MANY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES HAVE EXPERIENCE-
ISOLATION- AND- HOUSING. ACCESS
FULL ACCESS TO PARKS- IS REALLY
CRUCIAL TO OUR COMMUNITY- AND-
WE WILL DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
SUPPORT THAT EFFORT- AND ONE
THING TO KEEP IN MIND IS THAT
NOT ALL PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY OR ABILITY
TO CALL INTO THEIR LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIAL- TO INFORM THEM OF- OF
THESE POSITIONS SO I THINK IT'S
pSOMETIMES KEEP IN MIND THAT- FOR
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY THAT- THEIR VOICES
MIGHT NOT ALWAYS BE- HERDER AT
THE TABLE BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KEEP THEM IN MIND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW GO TO
LINE ELEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS GOING TO BE HERE WEBER
THEM AND LET FRIEDMAN DIRECTOR
CLIMATE RESULTS WERE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN LOS
ANGELES AND WE WORK ON THE
POLICY AND POLITICS FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE EXTREME HEAT IS
HERE IT'S GETTING WORSE ON THE
STATE IS NOT PREPARED IN LOS
ANGELES WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
GRIP OF A DANGEROUS WINTER HEAT
WAVE. I'D LIKE TO MAKE TWO
POINTS FIRST EXTREME HEAT IS
CAUSING A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
IT IS RESULTING IN PREVENTABLE
DEATHS ESPECIALLY FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND MARGINALIZED
SECOND ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED
FOR HEAT IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
IS WOEFULLY INADEQUATE WITH OVER
FIFTY COUNTIES AND FORTY AND
FOUR HUNDRED CITIES BOTH THE
STATE. FARM WILL BE HIGHLY
SOUGHT AFTER WE KNOW WHAT TO DO
HUNDREDS OF THE RECOMMENDING ONE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE PEACE PROGRAM AND
WE HAVE PROVIDED DETAILS IN THE
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
MEMBERS THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE WE URGE YOU TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE FUNDING
TO ONE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
FOR EXTREME HEAT IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. FIVE GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
MANAGEMENT'S MASCOT SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE BUILDING TO
CONVERSATION COALITION WOULD
LIKE TO ASK THE LEADERSHIP
COUNCILS AND REDUCE ECONOMY OF
THE ONE BILLION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BY ALLOWING
CAN BUILDING BATCH OF THE
PROGRAMME WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING
ONE BILLION TO CONSTRUCT AN
UPGRADE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
CENTERS LIKE SCHOOLS LIBRARIES
AND OTHER PUBLIC BUILDINGS.
REGARDING THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION SET ASIDE BETWEEN HEAT
UNDER I DON'T WANT TO RECOMMEND
THAT THE FUNDING BE DIRECTED AT
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS BUT
ALSO WANT TO UPLOAD A REQUEST
FOR ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR A
COMMUNITY TO SELL AND CENTERS
THIS COMBINED TWO BILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL HELP REDUCE
CLIMATE POLLUTION MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF THREE P. PRETTY GOOD
PAYING JOBS BILL RESILIENCE
CALIFORNIANS THANK. YOU THANK
YOU. WHY FIFTY. THE MORNING CARE
BLUE MEMBER MY IS THE LAST
WALLANDER I NEED DIRECTOR OF THE
K. AT THE OF MUSEUMS ARE
ASSOCIATION WITH OVER TWO
HUNDRED MUSEUM MEMBERS ACROSS
THE STATE WHEN THE KEY ADVOCATE
FOR THE ONE TIME INVESTMENT IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO OF FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
HISTORICAL ENDOWMENT FOR THE
MUSEUM GRANT PROGRAM WE ARE
THANKFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR FOR RECOGNIZING THE
EXTREME NEED FOR FUNDING THE
MUSEUM GRANT PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY
SINCE CALIFORNIA'S BILLS WERE
LOSING TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A DAY AT THE HEIGHT OF
THE PANDEMIC. THIS IS ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOMMIT TO CCHA
PURPOSE OF SUPPORTING PROJECTS
THAT ARE DEEPLY ROOTED IN AND
REFLECTIVE OF PREVIOUSLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
INCREASE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCIES CAPACITY TO OPERATE CCG
AND TO MAKE STATE INVESTMENT IN
MUSEUMS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS A REGULAR
OCCURRENCE. MUSEUMS ARE THE
STATE PARTNERS IN EFFORTS TO
PROTECT OUR CULTURAL HERITAGE
AND TO ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO EXHIBITS AND PROGRAMMING THAT
INFORMS INDIVIDUAL ACTIONS AND
PUBLIC POLICIES THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. LINE. FORTY ONE. HELLO ABIGAIL
MILE WITH ENVIRONMENTAL ENERGY
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN TRIED TO LAND THE KNOWLEDGE
MEANT INTERPRETATION AND EXHIBIT
IMPROVEMENTS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT PARKS AND RECREATION
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT
FLEXIBILITY IN USING ANY FUNDS
COMMITTED TO IT AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THE BACKLOG OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. WE
UNDERSTAND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS BACK TO THE PROP FIFTY
EIGHT FUND TO SUPPORT BLACK PARK
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS IN OUT
YEARS AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
ALLEY AS RECOMMENDATION TO
REPLACE THE REVERTED FUNDS
THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND IN
ORDER TO SUPPLEMENT CAPITAL.
OUTLAY PROJECTS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. FINALLY WE ALSO. THE
ALLEY- RECOMMENDED. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE A LIST OF
PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. I WOULD NO
LONGER BE FUNDED SHOULD THIS
PROPOSAL BE APPROVED. SEPARATELY
IN ESPONSE TO THE DISCUSSION ON
THE CLIMATE RESILIENT PACKAGE-
ON BEHALF OF ESCONDIDO CREEK
CONSERVANCY. I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE CALL OUT
FOR EXTENDED ENVIRONMENTAL
LITERACY IN THE NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS ASIDE AND SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS AND BROADENING
OUTDOOR EDUCATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS JENNIFER CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION AND I JUST LIKE TO
ECHO THE REMARKS OF MY COLLEAGUE
BETH PRATT EARLIER AND IN
OFFERING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ISSUE THIRTY TWO THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY FACILITY
CANYON PROJECT TONIGHT I ALSO
WANT O ECHO SHARE YOUR
GRATITUDE FOR BATH AND THE OTHER
PARTNERS BUT ALL THE WORK OVER
THE LAST DECADE TO BRING THIS
MONUMENTAL- AND PATHBREAKING
PROJECT INFORMATION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO MEETING WITH YOU AND
OTHERS- AT THE GROUND BREAKING
LATER THIS YEAR ARGUED ARGUED
WITH UP TO TEN MILLION AND-
FINISH THIS. FINISH THE PROJECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. M. LANIE
DOWN ONE- BEFORE WE GO TO THE
FINAL COMMENTARY IF YOU STILL
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. AND GO TO
LINE FORTY THREE. FIVE FORTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
GUN. MISTER TERRY TO FEAR
APPEARS THAT WE HAVE NO ONE LEFT
TO THE COMMENT THANK YOU OF
PHANTOM CALLER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ASSISTANCE OPERATOR AND
THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR HEARING
FOR TODAY- I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT- NEXT WEEK. WEDNESDAY THE
FIFTEENTH THE SIXTEENTH THERE
WILL BE NO- SEPT THREE HEARING
I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL SADDENED BY
THAT- AND WE WILL RETURN THE
FOLLOWING WEEK- ON THAT ARE.
NORMALLY SCHEDULED TO DATE DAY
AND TIME- AND- BEGIN- REVIEWING
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU ALL FOR PART YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE ARE ADJOURNED.